oh yes I would have to pay up so the
brown to the South Stream starting okay
huh
Raj me to second hello yes of course
right Raj me tune is here I had I had my
doubts but Raj Mattoon is always here so
hello everyone welcome to the 100,000
subscribers let's call it celebratory
stream this is Yan Almighty and myself
will be joining you for some four hours
now the stream is gonna last for about
four hours and for for the first two
hours we're gonna have a nice leaches
tournament and as I see we already have
over 1500 players so far we have sixteen
hundred and thirty eight players and a
lot of the title player the players
joined us so although it's not a titled
arena it's mostly an untitled arena but
still a lot of title players after that
we'll be doing some challenges but not
for too long probably for about an hour
and after that we'll be doing the
picking of the winners we'd have to see
how the giveaway will go as we do have
10:10 prizes featuring featuring ten
Amazon gift cards and two championship
chess sets so after all the all the work
is done then we're just gonna enjoy
ourselves play some chess and you know
enjoy some some chess jokes so yeah how
you doing very good I hope you are ready
for this epic stream definitely man so
thanks for inviting me
yes of course and once again I will take
this opportunity to congratulate you
thank you hundred K man thank you what
what an achievement I thought I might to
do that because you all here you also
congratulated me last time
some I'm so predictable yes
hopefully not nothing chess yeah yeah
thanks thanks for having me I'm glad to
be here I see already over 5500 people
on the stream so I think it's going to
be awesome
yes most definitely so yeah look
and the number of the of the players in
the tournament is is growing like like
all the time so yeah I don't know I
don't know what I think also most of the
players joined right before the
tournament yeah probably
maybe it will pass even 2,000 thousand
players and there's they're still half
an hour till the tournament starts so so
let me just let me just check who's here
okay let me see there's a new coach
three Voinovich Wolff a motivation chest
by DMR Johnnie pant I already mentioned
Rashmi Tunis he's always first but we we
already had a couple of people before
the stream even started like Marco
Markovski he's a he's always here on my
streams we have Jimmy Synesius Anisha
and Captain Nautilus and ham so I - yeah
those were the players who joined even
before the stream started yeah the chat
became really fast
since last time I got a say yeah
vehicles long name it is unfortunately
not playing I invited him that I mean I
don't know if he will be playing in the
tournament but I invited him to join us
on the stream but he had some other
things to take care of I really yes just
wise also chess wise okay and okay yeah
I think he played a the arena Kings
yesterday yeah I also yeah I saw it
he wrote like a post on it or something
but okay maybe he joins maybe in the
chat for a little bit Daniel subbu from
Moldova Ronaldinho Herald Ronaldinho is
at the party there was supposed to be a
lot more people here today just his
plane they say it's just that for
playing really that that would be also
very nice
Jerry Jerry is playing hi Jerry he might
he might also be streaming
yeah okay this is a I don't think yeah
I'm pretty sure this is the record we've
never had so many people here
arise my Tunes knows you are young ble
which ok ok so for those of you those of
you asking we will not be playing in the
tournament we will be featuring some of
the games from the tournament commenting
something on the moves and enjoying the
chat with everyone and if if any anyone
from the chat is playing and you face a
strong player or a title player do do
write in the chat that that you have an
important game so we will we will try
and feature your game in the livestream
hey mister Wow
yes well we will probably feature as
many as many people as we can it's a 2
plus also I don't think the game 2 will
last very long yeah but just enough to
enjoy them so medal is somewhere around
here and underhanded eyes here asking
where is the rakia rakia comes after the
tournament but we do we do have some
celebratory beer radio show so cheers
everyone
yeah where is penguin penguin did join
but then he enjoined I think a day ago
but he's a very busy guy who who knows
yes there are some very strong players
in the tournament but I think that's
that's an understatement
but yeah don't be scared or anything it
will be a good one
yeah so so far in the first 10 we have
Grandmaster fee glued that's like feel
good only fee glued we have grandmaster
the warning am astonishes grandmaster
nirvana 95 feet a master hawk 20 feet a
master toy walk national master 12 teen
feet a master pigeons feet a master of
white and Grandmaster sailor 1 951 so
that's that's that's quite a start-up
and
yeah we already have seven over 1700
players in the tournament that's like
that's like a pretty big tournament I
wrote I read a very good comment from
the guys so they said that we should
actually drink the whole case of beer
yes and then play bullet against each
other and comment on it but how we only
have one PC but ok in this room or maybe
for the next video maybe we can use our
phones you know and recorders ok yeah
the dog so now I'm actually yeah in
front of the dog sorry for that but he
he'll he will join also yeah I think
I'll move away from time to time
I guess he will jump on the couch or
something he had he had a nice walk so
III think he'll be alright
yeah there are a lot of players here
yeah I can't play since I'm the I'm do
I'm the one who organized the tournament
and given out to the prizes I mean let's
let's not kid ourselves it's not like I
would win but still you know on some off
chance that something that everyone else
loses their internet connection maybe
and I win you know I couldn't give up
the prizes
yes that would be totally unfair dude
you just one thousand people watching or
that is that's a good milestone that's
awesome yeah so yeah we do have we don't
have 20 more minutes before the
tournament starts so in those 20 minutes
we we could accept some challenges if
you agree that's fine if somebody wants
to play so hey chronal dino do you guys
I guess yeah I think Ronaldinho is
already having some rakia yeah yes
calling and Lazaro
although both of them are registered in
the tournament so you never know they
might they might play maybe on the
phones so a lot of people are actually
asking for Magnus Carlsen
maybe he joins yeah
I don't think I don't think they need
the donkey or drunken Stein will join us
he had a very busy week
battling Hikaru in Fisher random so I
think he he prefers to chill no no you
play I'm just gonna I'm just gonna enjoy
the chat okay okay
and the chat is very busy so what should
I do so to go other checkmater that's
okay I think that's all although just
uses there are different tabs so the
tournament stays okay with me don't just
do it like this
I'm a-gonna joins Leighton berserks
yes that might be so yeah that's his
style so okay let's play a game quickly
but only casual games so yeah yeah we're
gonna be using my account alone only
casual games it would not be fair if
there were rated games just network will
win it yes that is definitely definitely
a possibility yes he wins a lot of
tournaments okay
so just quickly try and do some so now
I'm playing and a lot of title players
are actually watching so I should
improve the game or something no you
think that you think they're watching I
don't think they are I know they're
watching of course Hey
open-ended a which is here yeah we were
just enjoying ourselves we're waiting to
see some spectacular games so definitely
waiting for some of my subscribers to
defeat some grandmasters and
international investors so I can feature
those games on my channel that would be
very nice Putin Putin is registered in
the tourney but he's actually having a
celebratory party as he just had a son
he he actually named his son Levin after
yeah the great after the great Levin
iron yes
can I take care I guess I can take it I
guess you could maybe even take this
then take on c3
regular chess no commenting alpha zero
should play yeah maybe someday a Shay no
man thank you thank you for your offer
but we already actually ordered pizza
yeah yeah but but you know if we're ever
near by a we have adres a cafe uh yeah
we're gonna accept a couple of
challenges now just just before the
tournament starts but then we will
accept challenges after the tournament
after we proclaimed the winners although
I don't know you know it is in the
description in my channel and also in
delicious tournament the prizes will be
awarded after two or three days I
probably after three days after the
tournament ends that's probably how long
it takes to weed out any possible
cheaters from the website yeah I saw
that you are now having some shirts or
something no what do you mean because I
saw some comments that someone will buy
your shirt or something yes what does
that mean
well I have no idea okay I'm not in the
business of selling shirts okay did you
did you mean this one I don't know this
is Mario even this is our mother's
girlfriend just commented we missed it
oh there now she will be mad now I'm
gonna hear it oh man again again
sleeping on the couch with meadow yes
come on this is not my day
okay should I play faster yeah a bit
faster but ok yes I they lose yes I I
have ordered some t-shirts and but the
problem is not in the t-shirt so the
problem is in the design for the
t-shirts as as
the guy that was making it took a little
bit longer but I don't mind as he did a
really good job so you you will see
probably I will I will give up I will
give out some limited edition t-shirts
in in a in a week or two DiMaggio's says
that his rating is only 1000 well that's
not really a problem because there are a
lot of people with ratings like 700 and
800 so 1000 is not little
oh sorry crowning I didn't saw the
comment yeah oh try and fight Ronaldinho
before the tournament starts so maybe no
not gonna be no Philippines they don't
pay to fill opinion yes yes there are a
lot of challenges okay is achilles here
Keeley's 36 hello hello and thank you
for me Ron hey Sam what's up
I don't think Achilles is here okay
let's try and be a little yeah okay
playing with the home guys where is Phil
opinion oh who knows that's that's a
good question but whenever we search for
someone we never find yet there's no way
okay Philippine you're here today here
is all right is that the right one yes
yes this is the right one okay oh yeah I
see a lot of games against Filipino well
I mess up your score now no it's it's
casual okay there are no rated games
yeah this is once again I have to repeat
this since we are both using the same
account please do not challenge after
the tournament to any rated games or
only non rated Patrick how long did I
plan to keep the stream going exactly
four hours so we started at 6:31 p.m. so
that will be like 10:31 p.m.
if that is four hours I believe it is
there's a new top-rated player in the
started list okay we will check it out
Papaji is that gob or pop if it doesn't
double pop you you guys are yes it is
gob or pop you guys are in trouble okay
so I see a lot of no even famous players
are joining famous well I would call him
famous yes okay ah yes that is a good
question
Glock oh sorry Eva will there be a
brilliant surprise in the tournament who
will be yes but there is only one
problem we would have to see every game
played in the tournament can we do it
over the weekend I think we will need at
least at least 100 volunteers to help us
look for the game that will win the
brilliant surprise yeah we can do it
over the weekend yeah we don't have to
look at all all the moves you know if
there's not a gambit in the first three
yeah no brilliant surprise for you or be
for personal or something like that yeah
oh is this come on no oh he's crushing
you definitely man hmm but um I'm okay
with this Dario did Sony the giveaway
will be done after after the tournament
maybe the problem I thought it'd be best
if we do it immediately after the
tournament so you know all the official
work is done and then we can just enjoy
some chess yes the Evans gambit he who
plays the Evans gambit will will win the
brilliancy prize lucky loser prize there
are no lucky loser prizes aniket beat
Gobber pops oh no worries there okay
anacott I believe you man
Fernando uh yeah I did say in my video
that you have to play at least 20 games
to to enter the tournament but the
tournament will last for two hours so I
think I think you have time to actually
play those 20 games Oh John Dennis I
believe you're referring to both Winnick
if you mean in the return match no no
come on
congratulations Philippines what
happened it was a stalemate it was a
stalemate all right so how much okay
still time for another game okay yeah
that's that's always that's my thing
okay you can play from the from the top
chlorides casualty yes alright the
chloride is always a standard guest on
this channel yeah guys I would really
like to play against all of you but
there are a lot of challenges here so
sorry
yeah we will definitely play after the
tournament we're gonna do some
challenges but as I'm sure there will be
a lot of challenges you know we prefer
bullet but yeah yeah definitely with
this amount of players push all the
pawns
yes I actually prefer bullet even when
there aren't a lot of players so you
prefer hyper bully oh yeah that's why I
made the tournaments - Plusle so if you
can be berserk you play bullet yeah is a
good I do mean seems fair okay
almost mm yeah maybe yeah I think that
in the last last five minutes there will
be a surge of players coming but yeah
let's see
see ya because I think today in the
morning today they were like five
hundred or something a chloride thanks
man you're the best and I hope you
brought many chose jokes as just jokes I
always like to mention this chair jokes
are extremely rare so you know if
there's already a stream do use some
chair jokes in the stream you know there
are never never too many chest jokes
yeah thank you Tony same name same Cove
okay Annika I hope you do I hope you
beat I hope you beat everyone how do you
stop someone from using stockfish well
you don't but it would be very hard to
use it in in a two minute game I don't
know I was gonna I was gonna make a 1
plus so a real bullets tournament but I
thought what most people wouldn't enjoy
that but who knows for the for the next
tournament I will definitely make a poll
on the channel as to what's time control
should we use yeah I think there's a lot
of Tony's in the chat ok Trey Rosenberg
no not not to the Metro Xion joke please
not the frozen joke again some jokes are
anything but that
ok how are we standing with the
tournament we are actually six minutes
so I guess time for another game do
maybe want to play no I will I will play
after the tournament
ok that's fair so I had a very busy busy
day so ok casual trip oh so what we have
time
that's that's too much okay let's play a
bullet rotten blue cheese also a
familiar name if I might say is it
coincidence you play chess with four
horsemen it is that a joke or what okay
what is that King ah it's the bond club
he's doing the bond club against you if
you want first place then you will
receive prize immediately III don't know
what you mean
mara is right here he oh he just heard
me
yeah I would I was actually planning a
chair spin but the chair I'm sitting on
currently does not spin so yeah young
took the spinning one what now you will
never invite me again no III have to
have at least two spinning chairs that's
the only way that's that's the plan for
the next yes that's the plan to stream
properly or at least two spinning chairs
okay you're actually up on time that is
that is weird
yeah because you taught me how to is you
bend it very nice
you taught me how to play only chess the
night actually brief move and play the
next move and there are two thousand
people in the tournament that is just
insane okay time to push best one
what will he do rotten blue cheese ah he
wants to get stalemated
does he man almost not enough time for
the stalemate okay let's let's check out
the standing I'm not the expert on the
chair spin that's a good question
I also didn't know about this although
it is a 22.2 Plus always considered
bullet and your bullet rating is shown
but for some reason you need to have
twenty rated Blizzard games to play
that's like I don't know I heard of this
yesterday and I thought it was some kind
of a glitch but apparently it's not
because you know two pots always
consider the bullet yeah yeah I know and
also thirty seconds is also bullet and
yes yes but then you should have at
least 20 bullet games so you could play
but you need 20 blitz games to
participate in a bullet tournament I
don't know a bug developers yes I think
I think we will report this to leeches
immediately okay is there a berserk
price is there a berserk price maybe
they won't provide one I mean they were
only right for the top players who had
them but yes their crate or something
like that probably yes but if someone
really had a good berserk determined we
will award him nevertheless read my joke
what was the joke what what was the joke
Rosenberg will pay attention now still
have two minutes okay yeah okay that's
it two minutes and twenty twenty one
hundred and thirteen players berserk is
when you actually take half a time of
your initial time in in the game on the
tournament and then you earn three
points if you only started in five
points if you're on fire so I guess that
was clear enough yes and I think I think
there will be a lot of berserk as people
aren't really used to playing two plus
so
yeah I'm actually really really doubting
my decision to create a 2 plus so
tournament but what can you do
let's change it yeah for the tournament
no because it's probably better to even
do one minute or 3 minutes but I thought
2 minutes would eliminate eliminate more
cheaters and for those who preferable it
can always berserk and yeah but then the
opponent has two minutes but ok yeah
what can you do now it's yeah it is how
it is but you know this will be an epic
tournament
you know people people will speak of
this tournament for generations or
waiting so you know probably just
tomorrow but no I definitely tell
stories to my grandchildren although
this turn yes of the greatly chess
tournament of 2018 yeah a car accident
first okay
the chest is just too fast maybe for the
folks yes for now for now
no actually guys I'm not playing I will
be commenting with other money yes we'll
just we will just be showing some
featured games like I said if anyone
from the chat is playing a title player
or a strong or a high high rated player
just write in the chat important game or
something we'll check it out or better
yet just write your leeches nickname we
will find you and then we will feature
your game alive yes it starts in okay 11
eight seven six twenty two hundred and
sixty four hours three and don't have
okay so for now okay
we will whoa oh no yes we are
accidentally in the tournament okay do
you want to play no no no I will I will
resign this game okay I will resign this
game and withdraw yes yes the pause yeah
hit pause not back to the yeah pause
pause yeah yeah III forgot to unregister
from the tournament okay but yeah okay
we gave Sergio ski a head start there
because but okay it's it's a two-hour
tournament
okay so there are a lot of a lot of
players already at the top okay do you
okay
smiling friend yes we should have a lot
of a lot of games featured okay but as
you all know me okay you don't know
because I probably said this before the
tournament yawn is the tournament
director yes good one good one
IBM row Apple another blunder by me yawn
is the tournament director and he will
be choosing which games are shown during
the stream and I will just be enjoying
it enjoying the games and and of course
the chat so yeah this is just just the
title it doesn't mean that I really know
which games to show it will be just my
personal personal thing to choose yes
it's more of a task actually so this guy
just invited me to enjoy the chat and I
need to do all the work
yes but I will I will bring you beer
when you need okay so I guess fair will
we archive this of course I mean it's
are archived immediately if if you mean
the games okay also I will try and
comment it on the glade game of course
of course as you see six here
threatening all sorts of stuff that's a
great comment night-night to somewhere
95 even maybe to prevent this but okay
Evon cookies in the chat all 26 now
that's that's what I like to hear
exchange and maybe if you move the
bishop from g5 should be moved in then
Knight to g5 exactly and this is a
problem for a smiling friend but but on
the other hand that's a really cool name
smiling friend yeah yeah you know who
doesn't want
smiling friends oh yeah
KN CP 719 finds it right away yes and
although I think he could have easily
preserved this game but yeah it's very
early I think I think he knows okay it's
very early in the tournament there
should be six maybe oh here here's the
star of the show what do you want do you
want to go for a walk yeah
always want to go for a walk he only had
like ten walks today but yes we will
speculate the top GM's don't worry but
we're also respecting everyone that why
just was the Queen come on man oh okay
smiling friend smiling friend is is is
doing it yeah this is like the biggest
turnaround ever yeah and we chose the
right game yes we chose it was a perfect
choosing
I think refuses to believe this but my
good friend is down to 13 seconds can he
do this how can he do this this is yes
he's going to capture on g3 and and it's
gonna be at least a draw Oh awesome now
he's doing it he's doing it 95 Oh Queen
h5 this is like the best game ever oh
with check okay and oh he had made he
had made when each one when the night
was an f2 yeah but I think he'll do it
that that's a weird now we put the night
King goes out okay but he's doing it
yes I think he's doing it okay it's it's
it's an epic king hunt I think this will
be used in my next video okay and or
discovered check but by the three four
push and no Oh awesome very nice
congratulations meddling friend
very good this was very nice just
network let's watch the game from okay
okay
okay Gary fi there's a string though oh
this oh that was they're so intense yeah
good game smiling friend beating a 2440
player definitely an achievement to be
proud of okay in Gary fi berserk and he
is okay he is attacking fiercely on the
Kings side yes I think there will be a
lot of surprises this tournament yeah
okay yeah take on g6 Queen g6 and put
broke into the game but we can see that
stream dog is a supporter of leeches due
to his shiny green wing that's always
good
what was smiling friends reading I think
it was around 1900 1900 yeah something
like that yeah it was it was an epic
game and the opponent had twenty four
hundred twenty four forty something what
I saw yeah we want to see many more
games with those kinds of twists no I
don't think you I don't think he was
stock fish someone suggest in the
comment I was just then I didn't see how
the Queen got lost but yeah we were away
at that time but okay here we can see a
color of will he make it
Gary a fly he has a pawn I think he
wants to Fonz I think it's absolutely
impossible not to win this but then
again awesome man and now yeah thank you
James flame in iment you can just hit it
here and then you can go to sing the top
games every file is actually in the lead
no there is a Burger King mastery but
the jury is also Burger King oh he is
playing against Gannicus he had also a
frequent streamer yes yes yes actually
he's streaming at the moment okay so
let's see this game but this wasn't this
wasn't a berserk game but nevertheless
do we want let's look at berserk games I
guess they'll be more exciting are they
well but
a hard spot of a berserk game because
you see on the top there is always okay
only on the first game there should be
that orange thing Hey
greeting greetings l spiro me and L
Spira are playing one game for like a
couple of days now
oh the those corresponding game yes yes
it's really wild a lots of tunnels yeah
no not really
he has a he has a root can the bishop
against my queen and now anything had
happened I think he can actually force a
draw but we'll see
don't tell him that yeah I think he
knows it no that is that is definitely
not beard that is that is beer yes I
actually announced that I will mostly be
drinking beer before the tournament ends
and then we will be accepting some
challenges okay I am Gannicus is going
for the end game since yeah so it looks
much better on the Queen side for him
yes the material is equal but you know
yeah his broken games are drawn yeah but
he is much better on the Queen side if
he keeps one rook it should be enough
Sophie change now then it would be a
draw yeah
so this is pretty much a draw but we'll
see again mr. Gannicus isn't 25 2561 for
nothing I believe yeah what kind of beer
excellent one excellent one
yo yes it's kind of a yellow colour
home-brewed yeah only the best
yeah only the best for this okay can't
Ken black is black is no up a pawn so
what it's a lot more active for white
but what do you think should we do this
whole time like maybe go to one of those
classics like London classic and Tata
Steel in Jam beer drink beer and
commented on of grandmas
but they oh they already have official
commentators my dad yeah but maybe they
can for the next year maybe they can
think of somebody else yeah but that's
just a suggestion so maybe if some of
you would want to want us to do that yet
maybe tell somebody I don't know I'm not
sure I would want to do that it's just
for fun man
it's just for fun okay Gannicus has a
best poem but also Gary five has the
best bones congratulations Shane for
winning a game man I think this is
winning for black because he is in time
okay
oh no so far no no no yeah all the time
is much better yeah Gary fight
unfortunately yeah this is I think we'll
see a queen captures rook and then
pushing at the bone which is happening
right now okay we can go out and show it
yeah very nice Gannicus very nice okay
here we have a top game Oh open resin is
playing very nice you know opera isn't
also a supporter of leeches yes yes he
he always plays so this is some kind of
a French I guess was yeah it's a it's a
very high rated game okay
this is the game that you are familiar
with so yes I was high rated players
yeah hybrid players playing the French
yes I'm very familiar with that okay so
oh I could think of nothing worse so
yeah black is some problems Queen to h5
is an idea and yeah okay I will have to
study this game to see how to how to
punish the French yeah okay take on a
trait black is looking for some counter
play hey mister Yugi thank you
it seems really difficult to comment on
such fast games no no it's piece of cake
yes they are not there will not be any
meaningful comments
ATS don't have bishops they have comma
stars okay was that the chess joke maybe
I think it was twenty six hundred eight
hundred and fifty people in the
tournament okay see it from here yeah
but will view it after the game okay I
see that black is not looking okay and
here is yeah okay because I'm I mean
check out the standing yessir lizard is
first and this is the first game he
didn't berserk okay
now he broke broke in the first place
and he preserves the game now against
don't eat chess with show what should
not rise we will have berserk inna 2330
always enjoyable to watch okay
heyyyyy bay alien never saw one okay
thank you kebab man thank you Bob
thank you sweetie yeah yeah nice to be
back
thanks for our matter for inviting me Oh
provision okay somebody somebody almost
burgled let's try to go into the flat
but okay agamotto is handl handling it
it's okay now I'm all alone with 1828
people that is awesome awesome yeah it
is a home brewed beer and it's really
good actually
Oh Colonel Dean your joint
okay let's look at the game a for I
think c6 maybe take on my g6 now yeah
Oh per resident sees it right away but
yeah he I guess he won't have enough
time against dumped teaches only 16
seconds to win this game but let's see
oho so is the Ronaldinho was here just
just to say hello
yeah grab some supplies for the party
so Oh professor has 15 seconds and is
exchanged down no he's exchanger yes but
I think that I think that's enough for
over but you know you never know oh it's
so it's always intense yeah when you
berserk someone lower rated than you and
then you have to you know win the game
in ten seconds
Ronaldinho not Ronaldinho so yeah friend
brother-in-law yes the one the one that
played against Kasparov and now what
what happens now okay grab the phone
grab the other no oh oh there if I don't
think so I don't think so there you go
it's a problem okay but now yeah
Oh operation was sorry man a tough loss
for operation losing almost 30 points
professor our headrest okay okay I guess
the chest in some language right
yeah I believe it in Spanish yes maybe
yeah so okay yeah we can we can check
out professor as he's berserk in all the
games okay let's see the professor or
not the professor ridet 2047 in first
place
bruiser King all the games very exciting
can you turn down the volume
the movie volume I'm trying to play and
it's freaking me out
it's up man sorry
I don't know what to tell you I'm just
the director of the tournament yeah I
I'm in charge of the volume yeah I think
you have to reduce the volume on your
browser of the moves I don't think I can
do it
who's the guy without a matter worry man
my name is Yann Almighty and I'm also a
chess player I would say a good friend
from mother matter but that's only my
opinion okay yeah okay view tournament
and let's see so what happened professor
but let's just move on okay yes playing
an RA professor earned it but I don't
think you keep reserves another game
okay the thing is yes so my name is Yan
oh mighty chess player and a colleague
from ergometer
and a guy who is kind of frequent on the
last few streams so yeah you're really
on every stream I believe and let unless
a couple of first ones yeah yeah we
started hanging out so he said join my
stream and I said okay yeah you've seen
and we're neighbors so I seem to seems
perfectly reasonable yeah that's what we
do here in our hometown yes do YouTube
chess dreams you chess dreams and
drinking beer of course yes what's
happening is Professor hanging in there
okay from d3 man the games are fast so
okay can CP from South Korea from Rio
yeah
Cheverus is from Spain yes okay and he
did have a wonderful start to the
tournament but it's it's a long
tournament although although time is
flying
I mean it happens when you're berserk
all the games tend to lose one and then
you lose the fire you wish sure I am
Finn's was here
I think he's currently playing and over
the board's tournament what's that
what's over the board yeah I mean yeah I
mean yeah yeah I think I think he's
currently playing a tournament
where's the women that's that's a real
chest greeting yeah the women are where
are they always add the chest stream
yeah holder to be found
yes not nothing at the chest stream no I
did not give up on twitch I just I need
I need like two weeks straight to get my
twitch partnership going and then and
then it will be okay to stream on Twitch
because before I get partnered with
twitch I the stream lags and it's it's
not it's not very enjoyable on Twitch
really yes because if there are some
verified users which partners already
streaming and they grabbed all the
buffering then your your stream will
will suck okay okay
Thank You welco 26 nine nine nine six
and hello everyone for those of you who
just joined us he's six and yeah since
we only said this like in the beginning
we will first have a tournament and
after the tournament finishes will
proclaim the winners the winners will be
given their prizes only after three days
that's how long it takes leeches to weed
out to the the cheaters then we're gonna
be doing the giveaway will pick out the
winners of the Amazon giftcards and the
two championship chess sets and then for
the end of the stream until the end of
the stream will be accepting some
challenges and you know just having fun
like really killing it here against
Kay Kay NCP well I mean this could yeah
it's not drawn so you know it's not
although if you know goes with the king
it shouldn't be put the rock here yeah
rock to h2 King has to move but now it's
war
yeah
the closer yes he got him way to go
professor will he have time to check me
the professor really really knows his
stuff
okay he's moving now
yeah but can he do it yes he can
ten seconds should be enough yeah it's
plenty oh he doesn't want to grab the
pawn but he must ok Queen f6 next yeah
okay and this is the second time the
professor beat no the first game can CP
lost against the smiling friend yeah so
this is not this is not going well for K
and CP but okay you never know there was
a checkmate I think where do the stairs
lead the Stefan stairs lead how can this
checkmate huh checkmate well done well
done professor let's check out the
standings just make him very near mm-hmm
I guess first 31 points already 31
points yes sir twenty minutes of game Oh
provision is here through thick the
warning okay a lot of players here for
example baccarat who just created an
account as his rating still has a
question mark all wins they are not not
berserk yes they are not berserks but
they are all wins maybe he doesn't know
about berserk they want to I don't think
I don't think he doesn't know about
berserk okay dota his life yeah a funny
username yes
and that is actually pretty good he just
lost his first game and this is the
first game he is not Burger King I
believe I want to take it easy hey
father is Bosnia so the night got into a
car accident before f3 got drunk I
couldn't drive straight yeah yeah okay
definitely a chess joke yes I believe
last time it was he couldn't walk
straight but okay so thought is life
life is back in the game it always leads
back to you yes doesn't place yeah
the thing with leeches you cannot
actually go out go out you always stay
in the tournament if you joined one hmm
so many players streaming yeah we have
King crusher is also streaming okay that
is nice all in your honor
yeah I don't think they're streaming
this no I really well maybe it might be
playing something else how do you think
that it always shows wherever they
stream only chess doesn't matter I have
no idea how you mean that it actually
shows that they are streaming this turn
in the tournament but that would make
sense
yeah it I mean yeah that would be a very
nice touch really chess if they actually
made that okay let's see but Cora who
you said joint against Jim dinner yes so
will Bakura take a lot of rating with
the black pieces against the against a
very strong player okay spero you don't
know what berserk here is the berserk
here is you get rid of half of your time
and you get extra points for winning the
game yeah so it's like you want to tell
your opponent that you're like a lot
stronger than him your explanation was
actually so much better than mine so
much shorter I didn't hear your
explanation my explanation was like
three sentences more uh-huh well there's
actually the same thing that's that's a
very strong past bone yeah so GM
beginner yeah bokura maybe maybe he can
he can pull this off yeah but nobody
berserks here so going for the rook okay
those Knights can be crazy but there are
no threats there are no real threats I
would like to see many upsets here okay
rook sit very nice finding finding nice
moves
96 and rugby 1 probably yes but that
okay say he carla has there ever been a
pawn promotion to a bishop in a
championship game
in a world championship game I can't say
I've seen one neither did I
I think the people who actually promote
the bishop or just but actually there
are some positions where if you grab a
queen you lose and if you grab a bishop
it's it's a draw really yes my stalemate
you need to show me those ok beginner is
first it's a very very colorful lineup
da hurry up second daughter's life third
doctor Yosef reserved okay okay we have
feed a master justice boat with with all
victories okay berserk in his way come
on are there awards for worst played
game well III wouldn't mind giving out
an award but who would be able to you
know see all the games no not till again
who would be able to say this one is the
worst
do I have any favourites to win the
tournament no I definitely don't we just
want to everybody to have fun white
offers draw black declines draw come on
so why are you offering a drop always
play for the win always oh yes because
even if you draw on leeches you don't
get to continue or flame so yeah a draw
is good for no one if you want to win
the tournament can you submit games for
a brilliant surprise if you would be
willing to submit games for a brilliant
surprise I would be very happy about
that
okay gym beginner just won the exchange
he will probably double up on the D file
and yeah
there should be enough I guess bishop
hate to even know yes yes yeah why not
hmm okay Rob take Stephen yeah there's
no problem Bishop f5 before our young
characters yes my dream I dream we'll
think of that yeah we will we just push
yeah Bishop on e3 is a problem so nice
okay a nice game by GM beginner in the
beginner in chess yes but he managed to
lose one gaming in the beginning yeah
but he is killing it
yeah but I had 42 points 42 points but
also we have feeding mr. justice but
with all victories so far okay can we
actually see one of his games yes but I
don't think he's playing currently or if
he if he's playing it then there will be
a board here although for some reason
there's like a circle going on maybe
there's too much players in the
tournament how many players are there
probably 3,000 that's what I told you
3,100 yeah wow that's awesome awesome
okay then just go yeah go to the
beginner yeah go go go okay
he berserk this games reserve but he
preserved against a player with a
question mark so that's very brave he
doesn't know who he is yeah and this guy
already had with a question mark has
2277 rating yes you could be doodle he
could be someone from Norway no he
didn't say so this is a mystery guy
yes but he he's managing his time very
nicely and he is a no it's not a piece
of butt pressuring with the night and HH
almost a piece of I mean the voice is
better here yes no this is crazy good
that's crazy goodbye white yellow
captured on g6 men no no no you couldn't
toy I'm seeing no this is no doodle is
playing really good chess okay and we'll
make it daddy a question if it doesn't
think okay yeah that's the problem what
to do what to do yes okay later says
clearly a deceiving rating yes but it's
not raining it's a it's not raining it
has a question mark and now yeah he will
win yeah just what doodle wins okay
because of time but yes whoa okay dude
that was the ugly mystery for me yes so
gotta pay closer attention to him since
he meet the first guy yeah and he cost
him the flame that and yeah let's join
again the game from beginner because
both of the guys in berserk so this will
be a bullet a real ball game a real bull
game very nice and he's very angry now
yeah and his King is on the phone okay
oh very nice no King goes in the center
but okay Queens are exchanged no no
worries there going plans has more time
but for those bullet it's a poet you
even in bullet a pawn is a pawn oh very
nice yeah there are prizes so they are
asking about the prizes do you want to
tell the prizes in the tournament yeah
yeah well yes first place whoever wins
first place is $300
second place is 150 dollars and third
place $50 and for those of you who have
participated in the giveaway there are
also 10 prizes featuring Amazon gift
savelii that $25 each and two
championship chess sets so a lot of
prizes
do you so pop G is doing very bad yeah I
didn't saw him from the beginning of the
tournament
yeah but he's like he's like a real
grandmaster he doesn't play seriously
from the beginning yes he like starts
maybe maybe in an hour how many times do
you clear your throat today as many as
many as it takes
don't take on c7 okay very he saw it
even fenders and a very standard motive
in this okay we have a jury versus the
warning but okay it's a game okay the
berserk it's a berserk Jerry is a very
fast player both of them berserk yeah so
this is an interesting game okay so
black is a rock up and yeah I think
Jerry is in problems here yeah do you
know will he make it
yeah I think maybe maybe maybe he
creates a castle oh geez you two check
check okay
oh okay don't fall for that what what no
oh he could have taken it
yeah what oh I don't know this is just
playing it okay oh oh he resigns that is
a fair move fair move awesome but we are
not seeing a list of him here is berserk
King a lot of game how is the justice
ball doing still all wins and also yeah
GM warning all wins can we see it so you
say hover
yeah hovering click ah we have justice
both against Bob Jean and he preserved
him okay he's not afraid he's not afraid
to bruiser the Grandmaster okay
say something in your own language
okay now babji lost rope there um and
justice both just won the game giant I'm
killing it
awesome his second second place all
victories and now I think we'll see yes
I would have the warning against the be
destroyer
let's see I'll never get from Justin but
yeah I think I think justice both is
ready to take the lead and if he
finishes about about in the same time as
in first place this is yeah this is the
Scotch
some kind of weird variation by way no
the dog is not dead the dog is somewhere
here yeah the door is keeping keeping
warm at at the fireplace he's chilling
Queen III maybe yes we will show more
games from the question guy mark how was
the name the doodle doodle something
like that but he will he will jump jump
up yeah I saw his game yeah we will
check we'll check the second page as
well oh this is intense
okay huh
okay are there any threats
checkmate on the last night bishop okay
no not Bishop age seven made the bishop
Jean let's see yeah white is looking to
exchange pieces yes he's not the fun and
I don't think just the Boston girls or
it will be this the first loss from
justice but I don't think so
he's at one down I think he will do it
as check is coming yeah this could have
been checkmate actually yes
no not checkmate but I changed Oh check
first and now what check second yeah
just what she's waiting for him to stand
on oh he wants to give up a rook okay
this is it I guess now okay - oh okay I
think this this should be enough yes but
you never know who's a single game yet
so so that's not the rush to any
conclusions okay
he might not lose okay I don't think he
can win but I believe looky here
yeah but justice but he plays until the
end I see okay Queen and he's looking
for a still now maybe that platter okay
staircase checkmate oh we have Gorky
Pauline I'm gonna keep a lien from
Croatia playing against the warning
should we look at okay let's see it
boarding is still the warning is still
undefeated easy
no but you will see in the other one
okay and he is having so his sacrifice
yes but no not anymore
it seems that white is attacking pretty
fierce Oh
Gorky pulling just gave really awesome
checkmate on g2
the game hello good morning this is the
first loss for the warning
oh what a loss very nice from Gorky
Pauline and we have another grandmaster
okay just go to the second page here I
saw grandmas you're done with all
victories so we have another contender
for the first player prize I believe
let's see in this game oh okay so all
all wins so far so we are I guess an
hour into it no an hour into the stream
and 37 minutes into the tournament yes
one hour and 22 more minutes okay of
pure joy okay but this is where now you
see there's only one person streaming
and then when you go this is if you are
playing against a person who is
streaming so gorg Khan is also streaming
he is playing against him and real okay
so that's like who's streaming in the
room you are currently yeah maybe like
that because maybe if you go on the home
page you can actually see everyone see
oh yeah who is a cross everything stream
but okay it's very interesting yeah you
curse their streak yeah perhaps
every player would say he'll hasn't lost
the game then he loses yeah when we show
his game maybe they hear us talking
about them and they get nervous or
something nothing happened to my over
the board tournament I still have to
play two more games one tomorrow and the
one on Sunday those are the two last
games okay now yeah exactly so now again
mister Joran VDS is exchanged down and
maybe he will lose the game no he
mustn't yeah because then the legend
will be is we have cursed him say
something in your language buddy
ah there it is did you like it okay is
that checkmate episode yeah no no no it
is a six damn
but now some ideas I thought he had it
yeah but check and check Ruki Oh doesn't
work but he will try yes
so I don't think I don't think he will
lose this one I'll pick up one g3 yeah
but this rook it's always hard to lose
that first game after that it's going
yes then you get the strength from the
rage yeah okay yes I then then so I
remember you
you were you were from the beginning
again we cursed another one and yeah do
we see any player no I know everybody
has a loss everybody okay for now second
page and the second page probably there
are players who joined a bit late yeah
so okay also I don't see in Deauville
anywhere I don't think it was do well do
but okay you can do them you can always
click the the top game for now okay but
you know I'm not saying you're the
tournament director and the tournament
director needs a beer yes okay coming
coming
Thanks so the warning is actually three
points up and this should be enough for
him I guess to to easily convert this
okay against mr. motsek and I am from
from Poland and mr. warning is yeah he
didn't say here he actually only plays a
bullets probably one minute but okay
whoa
now this is intense both players have
only five seconds
and what will happen no nobody takes the
piece okay and this is stalemate oh so
I'm not the only guy who still meets his
opponents it happens on the high level
as well
so thanks for the beer
oh we have some new guy cuppa buds
quezada something also joined so let's
again watch the warning since he is one
of the top and clean oh okay hello and I
guess this is his birthday
maybe it's he does young 2003 2003 18th
of January 2003 cane yeah oh that's 15
that's not too young but okay
it's Viacom over there no via KHOU
decided to teach us nothing better than
a cold beer on this nice dream yes that
is that is truth
that's one beer over here here you go
but it's a it's fascinating how many
people are actually streaming yeah so
many but you should definitely check
that is it like that because I'm not
sure if those ones who actually were
shown there yeah are the same on the
turn I think it's exactly like this but
that'll be great man but I didn't see
King crusher on the top pages or
anything yes I mean there's over 3,000
people it's not very easy to get into
the top pages so it's good that the
tournament lasts for two hours because
then people have time actually even if
they lose games to come back always
those are positive a lot of people are
asking whether what does agamotto mean
what does that matter for me well that's
that is top secret
yeah once you learn it you cannot
unlearn it
yeah it stays with you forever yeah
although although this is obviously a
drunk game will Kane and the warning
accept this or will they just play I
think it's what this that came what the
warning resigned why why okay 91 I mean
the idea is to come to pick up the one
on a three but what foul but just go
around with the night I mean black
cannot do anything there hmm
okay so going playing berserk against
the beginner so whoa okay I guess we are
in for an exciting match did you fight
hmm
no g5f six I don't know jeans always
find a better woman doesn't have to play
the case the guy just saw stalemated
yeah it's never g5 I was tried you 500
but I think I think he actually wanted
that yeah one plan is when an exchange
but he preserved so you'll have to play
fast so do we have more information on
going to and who he is not not again
nobody wants to reveal where they're
from
yeah that's pretty standard here what do
you think is the most risky opening the
most risky opening to pull off here no
risk at all whatever you do you're
always better for me the most risky
opening is just a my player if I play e5
with black on e4 that's the most risky
for me yeah I don't know I guess I'm
just afraid against everything I would
say maybe e4 e5 Knight f3 f5 oh but I'll
actually like a 5
with white I don't like to play against
it and also I watch games where you play
the real hope isn't any time then f5 on
in the thuria I tried that two times and
once I managed to drew a tournament game
to draw a tournament game and the other
game I lost terribly so we see chess
network is breaking all the games and he
is holding his own in top ten and the
goalkeeper lien is also with 46 points
we have Jonah and but kebab asada is
really he's really gaining a lot of
points fast yeah he was the lowest rated
in top ten and he is doing really good
actually
yes and the GM beginner I remember when
he joined the tournament he was 2,400
now he is 2600 oh oh yeah oh yeah that's
great
not bad for a beginner yeah definitely a
good beginning of the tournament b3
immediately loses the game nah no beat
real amazing is that like some ready no
ready as f4 and but I'm a bird but there
are some I know there there is some
master Grand Master like b3 it was the
name of the opening do you maybe know
probably Larsen Larsen yeah I played the
I played it actually twice against a
national master in a classical game and
I did pretty well won one game and the
drew one okay slow bullet yeah not
berserk and slow bullet oh we have a
game between top two players oh let's
look at it let's see how how a top game
looks like Oh 92 yeah okay but then it
transfers in yeah well let's just see it
what happens okay this is just standard
stuff yeah there is nothing more
exciting than topic grandmasters playing
the scotch yeah and playing the opening
moves until 38
yeah / - Yuri
easily even ruk ruk before that still
theory yeah okay but they didn't berserk
yeah Titian it's a shame but okay this
will be this will be a long draw a big
inner is from Poland and warning didn't
say where he was from but okay yeah most
of the people don't sit down to write
where they're from really I mean I from
my experience I always played mostly
against people who just said you know
yeah okay yeah yeah I was more it was
more common to me to see where the
players are actually from Niger for does
it work here no I guess it doesn't if
the GM didn't play oh king of faiths a
nice move hmm okay pretty equal position
maybe you know I told you once it's a
long-drawn yeah and the time is pretty
even yeah it'll be it would be awesome
if we actually knew who the player were
really okay but it doesn't matter if
they win the prize they have to reveal
their identity okay I didn't know that I
mean but they really revealed the
identity to the leeches afterwards not
to you yes but I am NOT surprised so
okay I guess you will know but yeah but
it doesn't seem the rules that they
actually have to reveal their identities
yeah I know I know I just thought you
know maybe they would like to but okay I
will definitely ask him you can tell me
over the message or something yes it's a
deal
okay this is this is one tough game I
think black is actually even better here
maybe okay now I
the bishop is stronger than the night in
this opening and now we have some v6
ideas this bishop is controlling this
night coming closer yeah the night
there's also the time white is better
here even some time and even in the
position so 95 Bishop d6 and d7 so 96
yeah 696 ok
maybe go h5 f3 with the bishop yeah I
don't know 14 seconds oh okay it's okay
she's never gonna take it and now if you
take them I was winning because this no
no way he takes it b7
yeah and now he goes with the king so
yeah this is winning for white yeah
Marcus sink Sinclair I know I don't know
why YouTube decided to troll me making
my video 360 okay yes mr. beginner won
this game and let's see the standings
his first with 63 points nothing much
changed I guess we all have all the
standard players in the first ten let's
check the second slow goal at Jonah
babji's here 12 team were keep a lean
Beatles Oh a friend from Croatia
shout-out to him yes on creation like
from from that from the city nearby yeah
come on man you can do it yeah and he's
on and he's on a hot streak okay let's
let's see one of his games actually why
not definitely he's playing against
Monell David okay again not saying where
he's from
yeah as we said a guy from Croatia and
he is playing with whites here he is a
an exchange up but the black is kind of
a winged night of no night of three
night of three yeah is the threat here
but can can can the black king survive
this
Quincy eight maybe I don't think you can
move the Queen from guarding the G to
bond yeah but it's all with checks hmm
and now king of for rugby for hmm okay
ooh where's the check man ah Queen 27
yeah oh yeah the knight cannot but he's
gonna go visibly seven and then and then
King has to go in front of the rook but
Queen f7 was [ __ ] no it was it wasn't
work now the King has to go to the D
file and then captures before I would
check okay and now always well yeah now
still no okay hits with check yeah very
good a very good game by beetles even
though we looked and he's in the top 10
awesome very nice
what's because we know it what yeah what
one one more of his game okay he still
didn't pair up okay let's see now
so opera ISM back into a third place
keebler so a Sicilian kind of a strange
accelerated dragon something which
actually transferred in some kind of a
groom field maybe not really but yeah so
okay thinking I don't think it's really
important to name openings in in it such
quick formats
yeah they're just me saying smart words
inches so people think I know yeah I
think shares network yes blink can you
fix the screen okay what's wrong with
the screen honor
anuraag Sharma world can you face the
screen I don't know
okay well what what's wrong with the
screen yeah I don't think there's
anything wrong with the screen someone
someone would say something if something
was wrong with the screen
okay yeah is hey guys would you please
minimize the size of a chess board is
taking the whole screen but it's
supposed to do that but yeah I mean
what's the problem are the pieces going
out of the screen
no you hear you see how the stream looks
yeah it can't look looks fine to us I
think people are trolling us the bottom
part is uncomplete ah you want to see
the HGF II know I never show that in my
streams I just showed the the board so a
lot of people are just saying everything
is fine so yeah but III crop it like
that on purpose so the screen is just
fine thank you thank you
okay so beetles what do we have is
actually a pawn up in the same game and
the bishop pair so with Bishop to c6 and
a noise a seven I think I think this is
real
even if five now is coming so now the
dark square Bishop is strong he doesn't
want to exchange of course oh okay a
problem but okay wait check and then oh
he's coming for those poems don't
respond
yeah because those are doubled very nice
very nice
can you make the board bigger yeah I
probably could yes like we don't have to
show the entire board maybe just maybe
just the central squares that's where
all the action is okay
I'm when you were on the list of players
the last one is missing
oh I haven't I haven't set up set up the
stream so you can see okay yeah I only
set it up so the board would be seen
perfectly I will scroll down a bit yes
the scroll every time we we check how
the players are doing you have to scroll
at least once
okay so beetles is actually in a drawn
end game now a gray the Q&A video will
probably be done I will try to do it as
soon as possible
but there are so many questions I don't
know tomorrow maybe or on Sunday okay he
doesn't want to draw he will go for for
a win on time but I guess that's fine
they always do that if you have it yes
and oh and but this is still a win I
guess only chess I don't think it should
be yeah I mean me too but I know from
experience and white will win this
no he won't yes this is enough time no
no and it's a is it a win yeah it's a
win because essentially you can win yes
you can win if white really really makes
it happen so let's see if I scroll down
bro okay let's see it here up but not
not so not too much so yeah yeah the
10th okay okay okay so was it a little
one scroll is enough okay no we know
let's let's see
so buildings in seven place now which is
awesome but let's join the beginner game
since he is on the top but after I think
we should also look okay after the first
hour we'll we'll also look at some other
games maybe so that we look at the
beginner and a warning in the top
players
you're the tournament director maybe you
can help me and if you see some like
other matter said if you are playing
against somebody close to the top maybe
we can search for a username and show
your name yes but show your game yeah
but I think also if they are playing
against someone in the top that it that
we will see it yeah
in the little boards yeah yeah
definitely but what's happened here
beginner just gave up a queen why
that's what beginners do that is true
that is true but he also berserk so I
don't know I feel like beginners
position here what I look at that
undeveloped row can see a look at the
comments of people what where is the
compensation I guess there isn't one
yeah
we are wondering ourselves as well
what's you okay hmm I guess okay but
it's rookie night against the Queen can
he do it can Chilly Willy do it he has
like 30 seconds more so I don't know
we'll see no you could have taken an
angel yes but he doesn't want to spend
too much time sitting and defending okay
no oh he could have checked me yeah I
just tricked him
he's just tricked him but this is yeah
that is blocking ninja - f - no wow
that's that's that knowledge - ironclad
defense my beginner if he has more time
I'm sure he could take this oh really
okay yeah well time but he really he
really troubled Chilly Willy there okay
but still in the first place and how is
how is where is where is the yoora
Yura is on the 11th and still on a roll
yeah but he's not berserk in so maybe
that is why he is not but doesn't matter
you know little by little doodle is here
rule this here and he has all sorts of
results but very little losses only two
losses he's gay
okay Kings crusher is in the
so we got on his stream as well yes the
tournament everyone is streaming so
doodle last time he had to 2200 ready
yes so I think doodle is trolling
everyone yeah and laughing at it but
it's uh how will we American asking us
for a material is equal but either
official characters yeah now it's how
will he defend he can queen queen g6
maybe there is time yeah but the problem
is also queenie water and he opened up
the atari bishops a tree will he see it
well i think there should see three was
yeah but he would walk it bishop before
so there has to be something else to
find okay I guess we don't see anything
Bishop G okay before no I thought we
should pass for first hmm there's no way
to take advantage show the kingdom of h4
h5 yeah I'm sure he's gonna push it now
but no okay what's the idea okay he
wants to defend enough to okay no
capture I guess no no no King special
doesn't very intense game yeah and now
the long to come now the point I don't
know I think doodle is better should be
better okay five now g6 although no
Queen Queen h4 is coming Finch and this
is checkmate yeah on g7 awesome play by
doodle yeah very nice you really pulled
it off very nice okay hmm and beetle
says Obito's got a draw
no two trolls
- draws - giggles Wow okay wells do we
have chestnut rookies 20 do maybe know
somebody here okay let's check I mean I
know a lot of them but okay let's check
more okay
heretic from the beginning it's a master
class somebody who's maybe watching
because pearls video yeah maybe
and and and doing really well yeah
Gannicus is 30 night in the stream okay
okay we can check again by to walk toy
walk okay let's see how he's doing
okay in the middle of the game so this
is the end game and he's actually doing
pretty good Jagger Duff who we are say
my name
Fawad side find the hoodie guy candidate
master I think cm yes see him but but
the real question is what is LM a life
master and we checked it at the last
room I think I don't know why is it
called life master I think I forgot
about it because it made no sense but
it's I guess some title from the US they
I have we don't have it here
nope
yeah that's what happens if you're right
right a lot a lot of things elite chess
master yeah maybe maybe it couldn't be
LM leeches master this will be like only
Ally chess title but actually if you
google it I think it says life master
but what that really makes no sense
you're not just a master of chess you're
a master of life of everything yeah
enjoy well now if Bishop captures you
know to evoke put the bishop on the
wrong place there on b2 and here now I
don't think that he can go out of it the
let's see but
and he can just vote for the pond but he
will take on c3 and white is actually
faster here to come to the black pawns
on the Kings side if they exchange
everything so okay I know check but no
just King D 3 and pick up the d4 pawn
but no yeah it doesn't want to exchange
of course and now you just go okay sure
to a one hmm yeah F King goes okay wait
here we'll check it there and then I
think we should take one what I like is
just gonna check it bishop day one was a
better move but now what now Oh take oh
yeah it's a draw it cetera
unless it's not he can even take on a
fork area oh it's not a draw
you should have taken men on h4 it's a
wrong square for promotion so I think
but yeah the King doesn't yeah okay well
he managed to checkmate I don't know
it's intense
come on oh okay very nice do I walk in
the end
yeah in the first place
let's watch the game when planned again
barking against a grandmaster yes
untitled Claire in first place that's
that's what we enjoy seeing ha LM is
Latvia master yes could be could be
I wouldn't dare say anything in a
foreign language because I don't know
what people usually write about what I
mean usually people say so say something
in my language and then they write and
then you say it but you don't actually
know what you said so it could be
dangerous though Oh a very nice trick by
going playing playing Bishop to c4 and
then 9210 that he will win this yeah he
has enough time against the Grand Master
again really awesome so even now bring
the King closer but this guy is just
playing it man
very nice very nice she's going out with
the Queen yeah
checkmate come on Nevada load the board
awesome yeah and doodle is also here
yes Lulu is in eighth place and beetles
ah after that amazing strike beetles
lost two games yeah okay whether I he'll
pick it up and yes I believe let's play
let's see another game berserk by going
boy yes I believe it's pretty obvious so
he's a grandmaster it says here that the
goo implant is a GM yes but we don't
know who is maybe he will reveal his
identity just not likely maybe if he
mean you will know if he wins the award
yes but it's not in the rules that he
must do it yeah okay scroll to the tenth
place oh sorry sorry I forgot no I'll do
it man you're the tournament director
you have to scroll to the 10th place I'm
not doing my job properly yeah sorry
yeah there are a lot of questions for
the video so now you're making a Q&A
video yes okay so with it with a lot of
questions is it coming
well I will try to do it tomorrow or on
Sunday but with having two games to play
to finish the Challenger
I don't know if it will be possible but
I will try what's happening now so go
and plan going for those bonds in the
rock n game but man he is he playing
fast cook when plant yes now take and f4
but he did did he berserk he sees
everything
yeah he did well he preserved and if he
takes takes it doesn't work for for
black and now the a pawn is coming yeah
yeah I'm not sure I have three what does
it do he knows he knows yeah yeah and
now even that he wants to exchange
exchange a pair of ropes and then after
this one then the king will probably go
to and then even that okay yes why not
and if he captures King get five yeah
your each bone is doubled why not ruin
his bone structure Rock g1 maybe oh Rudy
for better better and okay not probably
this is just Ruby seven and he will be
even better
time capture would if you capture some
e6000 yeah and Ice King captures oh this
is just silly very nice by Guan plan
this is how you how you want to play a
rock endgame yeah c4 why and there's a
there's a reason to everything yeah I
guess okay very nice resigned after c4
obviously a very powerful move whoa
provision jump to the first place Oh we
started berserk in like a beast okay and
also I didn't saw this very longer let's
call it let's going Nix Nix Nix Nix Nix
Nix let's oh okay oh sorry sorry for
that let's watch again so this is a
problem for leeches maybe yeah if I go I
really have to go like this
yeah yeah
there's no other way to do it so if you
go from a stream to a stream into a
stream yeah infinity of streams okay but
at some point everyone will be streaming
yeah but and then what but then we'll be
watching that's the question
but you're just open a lot of tabs yeah
watching and streaming listening to
people they comment on the moves that
are playing against your stuff yes and
you know you're not just gonna be
watching one stream at once you will be
watching me at least a couple okay
his niece also Geico berserks a lot
because he okay
he might be slower 73 and Nixon was from
Philippines right yeah and I also saw
that Beatles won two games uh-huh oh
yeah and even even King oh they're nice
very nice move there you don't want to
grab it just like that and this is
pretty much it I think twenty seconds
will be enough to win this game did the
jury drop out of the tournament I don't
think so since he's still he's doing the
dog I saw him yeah he's in top ten
yelling yeah I'm also looking forward to
the Q&A video yeah me yeah me too I'm
just wondering okay
beware of the stalemate oh don't still
meet me so okay all linked down beat
loss is ten little sis I just lost the
game but Gannicus is always on a nice
streak and also doodle and also Gwen
planned
everyone is on a streak here yeah when
playing again in the first place let's
see that's that's a nice tournament when
everyone is oh we have GM who is that
the area Tortuga
from Russia Russian Grandmaster with a
very nice streak hmm I see Jerry is just
researching all the games yes yeah you
might lose some rating but maybe that's
the way to go King crusher also here
let's see doodle and gwendlyn this will
be an interesting
Oh neither of the guys who usually
berserk did brother in this game so
let's see maybe they know each other
yeah they are the only untitled players
in the top ten whoa this is quite a
matchup yeah I think this might be the
best game of the tournament okay who
knows
let's see for the brilliant surprise yes
okay regarding g5 but leaving the e5
pawn if I yep okay so was that planned
yeah
how should we know yeah it's an open
question for every g3 here yeah oh yeah
a lot of threats oh one thing when plane
is without mercy yeah just going for it
before no no the genius will never push
a point they were designed better moves
keeping the pressure on man just keeping
the pressure ok 94 ok
Queen f2 and they're definitely ah yeah
when plan wins the game with a nice
touch and it stays in Cliff's little
lead I'm really glad that the westerlies
now started the Burger King as well is
you the it's really don't forget to
scroll oh sorry you have to scroll oh
yeah Tortuga yeah join extra sometime
and here is in the top 10
yeah 30 at least okay not a little less
than 30 points from the top but ok let's
see go and plan playing against Horus
and yeah it's really good for the
tournament that there are a lot of
players with yes small amount of points
between each other on the top so that
it's not like one player which is 20
points above yes but it's still early
yeah it's still early to tell there are
still 44 minutes till the end of the
tournament so
doudou couldn't check making crusher
with a bishop at night versus long king
in the other game yeah I mean I mean
that's really hard if it happens it's
it's a problem if you have that little
time to really actually do it yeah I
only got that position once in a
tournament game and I was able to do it
but they had like all the time I wanted
actually I did a bit of video about it
and there were people telling me that
actually they learned from my video how
to do it over made me so proud so yeah
if you want you can check it out I never
I never actually tried learning it I I
did try once but I saw it was like
really complicated and no it actually
isn't yeah I also taught as well but
there are this couple of patterns oh
yeah you can just easily remember and
yeah you can just go from there and I
thought no it's never gonna happen that
position and then it did yeah exactly
that it never happens until it happens
but I think there was there was a case a
couple of cases actually between top
grandmasters and classical games that
they weren't able to finish that game I
think if you just Google like not it's
something like not able to checkmate
with the bishop and the knight you have
OSHA Nina Oh some woman grandmaster
playing and like one of the top
tournaments and it's just a video of her
not being able to check me oh so that
that is a shame you know but yeah I mean
there's a couple of simple patterns and
you can easily what see it game aborted
what happened okay also a question here
what happen yeah I don't know because
not know rating was attributed no no
victory it happened we aterna meant fine
with the tournament but so we watched
the game between oh maybe there are
cheaters yeah that's why they're playing
that good
so sad I think we just just banned them
that's like insane how do you how do you
treat come and cheat in a two two minute
tournament that's really the cost me so
many players their points that's like
yeah doodle and you know and we were
like watching them closely to see yeah I
know what let's just go go go watch the
next next game you just took another
untitled player quiz in the top stem
varga yes okay maybe another cheater and
okay let's not call anyone a cheater I
mean yeah definitely it's up to leeches
but that's just no I think we just
algorithm yeah they got it out there are
a lot of good developers behind leeches
and the website but it's interesting
they got banned when they were playing
each other both of them yeah because
maybe then it's easier to figure it out
I don't know that's a shame because we
we were like amazed but now I know why
we are amazed by their game yes such a
shame such a shame for chess yeah yeah
dude oh and what was the doodle and I
don't know yeah it's best if we never
mention it again
yeah I also think so rock h2
okay
okay this is awesome Osito orgy of five
okay yeah first take could you five
maybe once
oh very having a very tough time here so
I hope we don't have another case over
the middle I mean but it seems like
leeches is really having a problem with
these cheaters you know other are there
are cheaters everywhere you can stop
that but yeah of course and this is just
insane I mean from such a high level
game and do you wonder how they do that
I mean they like oh look into the
machine and just copy the move that fast
I have no idea I think it's a script
okay okay yeah this is a drawing game
okay but this is it should be drawn yes
it should but there are three seconds
under warning on the warning okay he
just it goes from side to side checking
and yeah yeah don't give up the rope
yeah no okay okay okay yeah we lost
those guys and now let's check out so
warning is hero provision I guess
okay here's he jumped really far hunt
over a hundred points for a player yeah
he preserved all the games but that is
very impressive but that that is what
Oprah does but doodle is still here so
okay dude wasn't the cheater that our
guy wasn't she ah
doodle just dropped dropped to below 10
yeah hmm very nice okay let's see Oprah
very interesting yeah but this is a it's
something you can't influence I mean if
we just can't can to do it
so exactly why but it doesn't matter
even if you lower the time format even
if you play a real bullet 1 plus so you
can still use scripts yeah but they will
reach us we'll figure it out in the end
I mean they will not be able to cheat
and win Gwyn plant was the name is very
yeah yeah exactly
and like other matter said and that was
the reason why he put it two minutes but
again even with two minutes yeah you can
be the scripts and the machine it just
goes with the most as fast as possible
but it makes it look so realistic
because yeah also couple games were lost
yeah that's the thing maybe try to make
it yeah yes here or something
probably Oh Oprah reason just lost the
game okay her just lost important time
yep haha okay will be a Tortuga 12 teen
and the warning cap Ketchum betul betul
season number 7
okay but we didn't check him out how
he's doing
let's see a game from Beatles again from
Maya David again like last time when we
saw him it was also playing against yeah
but that was it was a good game no black
problem with this Bishop here it's not a
problem but how will we develop this
side hmm well I think white is better
here
I mean night to III wasn't because the
other queen is trying to yeah it's
pinning this night well that's why we're
here to see how he figures it up yeah I
mean it's not like you have to figure it
out
yeah I mean I don't think anyone is like
having a tablet or a smartphone and just
ringing out the moves but varka 29 now
is banned now so is he okay yeah and
although although the players will
receive their rating back after the
tournaments the ones who lost after to
the cheaters today you know there was
important points in the tournament's
yeah that's a shame
yeah I mean I I have no I I don't see
how to yet probably probably we would
have to have some sort of a I don't know
you have to play 150 games before you
can join the tournament yeah I don't
know yeah but Takens yeah it's still
doable but I don't know if they would
bother it so I did my own yeah was the
game there was a nice sacrifice on e6 as
I said there was a problem on the
queenside so what further development
guy yes you see the warning really took
a beating there because he was that game
against the cheater and it cost him dear
time to catch our vision yeah now yeah
exactly so that's that's really ashamed
since you know and we had okay let's
check a game by 12 teen yeah we haven't
yet seen here's my Instagram friend okay
playing against fm nice who has more
rating points to him so disco oh they
did in berserk so they're playing
cautiously at least goodnight I know
that that sounds familiar
goodnight is let's see if the again a
person who doesn't want Akshay Akshay
mattress says that leaches returns back
the streak and cancels the losses of the
players who wants to cheat but really in
real time during the tournament that's
crazy yeah if that's true then that's
very impressive
yeah I had no idea I mean even for me I
am so for those who you don't know I'm a
computer programmer and even for me
that's like
yeah a pretty pretty insane and they
received their tournament points as well
says anacott but okay they I guess then
they get a lot of points right away and
everything but so everyone I wonder I
wonder how they implemented yeah yeah
because that's that's a really that's
wild algorithm because the cheater has
been playing for a long time you know he
damaged a lot of players yeah yeah but
yeah as I said it's usually tooks a lot
of time to actually figure out yeah so
the king came here seven yes that was
there was a a wild King hunt from f2 I
had one when I started it wasn't a kink
on me it was a king walk like maybe it
was a voluntary stroll
so yeah twelve teen I lost the game your
Instagram friends like I could say you
can't hurt me them all yeah but maybe we
are a.cian grabber puppies v I told you
he will try he'll start playing after
the first hour okay then that's how
Grand Master's roll
okay can we see his game let's see it
but you know what happened
we actually yeah he was this first
couple against the cheaters huh no no no
the last guy the the twin team just
because we watched his game then he
started losing like we are the curse
yeah we are the curse of the stream okay
let's see so pop G returning and we are
VA Tortuga a new Grand Master who joined
later in the stream yes and with much
better time control okay now as it
should be I don't want to predict
anything but I guess Bob G is in the
worst position just because we watched
yeah but well let's see but it's it's
the worst position on the list
doubled pawns okay it's playable but the
Apache has much less time hmm okay okay
you have a even an answer from Andre
about a recovery algorithm yeah okay
we're not that said I mean we all knew
that cheating was a possibility and that
we there's absolutely nothing we can do
about it but you know you always think
now it won't happen yeah but I I'm just
thinking in terms of like um you cannot
really bring him back to the path he
should have gone if he like played
against real players so even just giving
him points against the cheater wouldn't
be I guess the fairest I mean in that
position for him it is the first thing
to do but again if you think about other
players isn't the fairest thing to do
just bringing him on the right path
there yeah I wouldn't say you should
give him all the points maybe some
certain amount of points but yeah that's
there's like a totally certain role down
sorry so that's a totally different
discussion yeah okay so who is who is
back in the top ten let's check some top
20 top 30 okay no holding up
we have only title players now so I
guess chilly willy is here chilly willy
is here yeah and I saw I saw Jerry is
also on a roll
you see okay I think you want yeah you
want oh he won't well berserk king he is
berserk in most of the games yeah yeah
we can check ball game yeah let's do it
and oh and this would be Babji if you
preserved him yeah why not desert him
yeah why not
go Jerry play for the fun I don't think
I don't think God or pop is impressed
mm-hmm this place casual you know yeah
yeah but enjoys the game enjoys the game
yeah that's the thing also like grandma
you user says cash incentives attract
people who want to cheat essentially you
know that's what your grandma says none
of the user username but probably my
grandma as well yeah yeah
those cheaters and leeches yeah they're
the worst I played a lot of sites but
those are leeches and kanuk and jerry
pull this off I mean the hey essentially
at some point he has to sacrifice for
the okay g5 wasn't the best move here
man hmm he has to sacrifice for the e8
bishop and is that's just a matter of
time oh yeah that's losing now for black
yes but even on time and in the position
captures captures and then hides with
Jeff yeah hmm it was a brave thing to do
not join no let's crawl down and beat
off his back on a roll okay we didn't so
gave him for a while so I thought maybe
he would face a pop now okay but they
already began there they're mad prior to
that okay so we have 28 minutes to go in
the tournament I think yeah mm-hmm
I think we're coming closer and closer
to it I think so who was it the warning
or the beginner Oh No
Oh Purvis Oh Perez is in first place
yeah oh poor vision is really hammering
it yeah Jerry we lost because we were
watching kit yeah
what can sorry Jerry what can you buy so
you know I see someone doing a nice
streak and then of course we would like
to feature that game and then that
happens but
you said do you maybe know operas from
before or something like that I know him
from leeches oh he was like always
playing and always meeting up people
I always hanging out on leeches yes 25
hmm
did you [ __ ] doing that what seems
reasonable
I mean he's losing the rope nevertheless
so this is also okay I guess but the
king is wide open so Bishop e5 man don't
be a grammar nazi man what's why what I
know it's what the unifier says about
himself
okay yeah lishus
they played actually a couple of games
over the mobile app and it's quite good
actually if I might say delicious mobile
app yeah I mean yeah but not I mean it's
always a problem when you play against
with an app yeah it's a lot slower but
okay I mean it is what it is so but it
my friends it's not that bad
yes a friend Beatles got the piece back
but he is under severe attack will he
make it
Hey no at the road a rock lift from d3
to h3 what sounds with check and
what would Bill do now he has to do
something because 20 seconds is on the
clock
Rudy eight no yeah I saw that but oh the
Queen oh there goes the Queen and now
also you could have captured with the
Queen on g2 and there are captures
awesome recovery by beetles your nice
paducah helps you a little bit there
yeah maybe 4175 players yes I think
that's like the biggest tournament is
that a record I would how definitely
think some I don't know I think there
was four thousand players at one
tournament and leeches but okay can't
remember
Chile really the the last untitled
player in top ten is the only so let's
let's check out chilly willy
yeah I guess yeah Willy have you
scrolled you have yeah I scrolled the
line against Witek okay okay chilly
willy hmm now it's getting more and more
tense more and more tense 25 minutes to
go what do we have here some Sicilian
maybe yeah definitely and one to zero
okay
I really really want I don't want to
believe that all the untitled players
are cheaters so yeah it doesn't mean if
you're in top ten and untitled with oh
yeah cheater who would name their
cheating account chilly willy makes no
sense and beatles still still in number
seven and it's all very cool i mean
everyone's very close only over really
just jumped yeah Oh provision from
Netherlands playing against Beatles oh
there is death the gameplay let's see
can be no stop oh the almighty Oh
provision okay yeah there is hmm okay he
has a passport here but this king isn't
looking
- good yes but so that's others over
here 92 hmm okay black cannot castle so
a four here okay oh this is a tense game
no no there is a castle
yeah but how can he I don't have it
there have been some annual events like
a 24-hour marathon and leeches so maybe
that tournament had more more
participants okay probably she'll Doreen
yeah probably like in maybe even 10,000
Oh
but beetles is getting crushed here yeah
checkmate
Oh prevalence showed why he is in the
first place yeah and his 20 points have
had of warn of the warning
yes but yeah unless someone stops him
he's just gonna pile up those points
yeah let's do you have a preference
maybe okay let's see top 20 top 30 let's
see it has to scroll a bit did we did
okay okay well let's scroll doodle is
also here okay let's see top 30 okay
sailor from before mm remember him
ostentatious also hawk is here nice just
lost his only two games
whoo nice yeah he was the first two
games but he joined late okay I think it
we're getting very close to to the end
of the tournament so I think we should
follow the leaders now okay let's see
Oprah is on again against dr. Joseph
yeah I mean okay
that's the thing as well that I like and
think about these are players who will
then jump for joy there was there was
there was a clean wind for Oprah for
opera yes okay let's go with chilly will
again so what I wanted to say is for
example you're in the in the lead or
something you're ahead of a player and
then suddenly he gets 10 15 points
because he lost cheaters yeah so is this
fair to you who like thought I will now
not berserk because I'm clear ahead of
this player and some like I'm just
thinking about all of these use cases
it's really but I know that it's hard to
reach us all so what should you do
I mean this guy I don't think you can I
don't think we can you cannot cover all
the use cases and you cannot keep
everybody happy
hey Kirk Apollo it is the blue Yeti the
blue Yeti I would recommend it to
everyone
okay what do they have here a need for
game okay chilly really expected an e4
guy here need for I think generally oh
it's chilly will again stopper mmm I
think this could be the game that
decides the tournament Oh
building it up at all opening the H file
opening the H file this move was this
Bishop doing all night said Oh Perez
I don't know and it's interesting that
he got the black pieces against Chile
Willie
okay oh nine of three okay okay nope Oh
provision now I know why the bishop is
on eight seven to defend on i5g for no
no no they always find something better
are all of my moves dead bet capture a
knife fork no yeah maybe no I don't know
yeah now everybody's saying everybody is
crossing but I don't think so yeah chili
really is just okay but you know chill
guy yeah oh he did capture net for ya
and now what king was over vision
listening to me and now his doomed
yeah I think that's the reason
okay guys I don't always see the best
for always sometimes so but this is okay
for the tournament since if all provenza
lose this then you have more chances for
the others yet no produces and he's
losing the streak as well but okay the
warning is 19 points behind him
let's check somebody else but he also
kick it from Spain yeah the warning girl
yeah the warning is not berserk in his
games that's why yeah he wants to reach
him he needs to let's see okay let's see
his bruiser King okay feed a master more
on his three pawns up well he yeah I
think ours enough time of course yes I
don't think there's a problem here we
are not playing because we don't want to
it's all I want to enjoy the show
yeah no but I mean III organized this
tournament so I put up the prize money
and it's I don't know seemed pointless
to play and to win yes of course
but you know there would be some
cheaters so you never know I mean I just
want to play another mantra told me no
don't play I know you will win so yeah
leave you live somebody else doing so
okay it's only fair okay now it's it's
pretty much over hmm okay but Oprah will
pretty soon regain his streak probably
but I'm very interested how is how is
chili really doing she lost one game
against topper no no he then lost and
then won playing really fast then hmm
then we I don't think we watched the
game for with kicad no no we didn't
let's watch one of his games you're the
director he is in the top okay first one
okay the curse is broken
yes finally and Oprah just lost who beat
him I see that no no it probably is but
okay this could be interesting here
against Tortuga yeah I think we will as
the tournament is over in 15 minutes I
think we will follow only the leading
players now okay so it would be only
fair yeah what do we have here black
trying to exchange Queens but yeah
here's a pawn up and the pawns are on
white so he comes closer and a5 Bishop
to see it was very very nice
why g6 what'd you say there's a reason
after Skechers no hmm what they're
playing so fast but they have so much
time
if might be three yeah but then again
Bishop c8 hmm very nice c5 b6 or before
thank you quiet corner thank you
b5 not yes spero youtube does rule and I
saw her video with with the cats I was
very impressed
oh is that the guy yeah I sent you the
video and he composed the music it was
very soon
I also saw the video with the cats
awesome man
I mean if you like cats and you like
some good old Final Fantasy music then
you know you can't go wrong so now yeah
it's no it's drawn now it's just drawn
oh there goes the bishop and Oprah's
upper winds you want the bishop yeah
just doesn't mr. Tortuga they don't have
enough time to actually go and go and
draw this game
okay so again with opera vision and
chest I took both of them berserk
alright the game to see that's the game
to see okay that's only that's only
polite you know if someone berserks
users right yeah of course
okay some kind of a caro-kann okay just
sit and enjoy the show
yeah those poems are written are really
coming yeah so white is attacking on the
Queen side and black on the Queen side
[ __ ] side so 94 doesn't want to take
I won't take as well okay okay go back
but you know spending very little time
okay
see six yeah oh okay
covering both sides of the board 95 now
okay
doubling up on the sound drink I don't
know anything anything can happen here
oh yeah and even though okay capture an
object first with the Queen no yeah yeah
I also think so although what okay take
the rook okay check and yeah but the
thing is no Queen two three oh no I know
Jerry spawns are coming ninety-four no
[ __ ] hmm three
what can you whoa okay yeah but still no
it's just a matter of time checkmate yes
checkmate the bishop is covering d6 very
nice come on
Jerry Jerry one yeah oh she was covering
d6 whoa what did I sorry I think you you
miss licked something I don't know to
rejoin the tournament okay that was that
was intense I was going to analyze the
game
Oh Jerry may have may well have just
ruined his tournament yeah because
warning catches him now yeah but go go
for the game is we have very little time
okay
we must we must see the final few games
so Oprah's on the warning are battling
for the first two places and there is a
battle for the third place
yes and Jerry just crippled the crippled
the hopper vision pretty hard
hmm okay c3 yeah guarding before it's
standard things for the French yeah
we'll be playing challenges for the
tournament although I will just have to
take like a five-minute break five to
ten III will have to probably take medal
for a short walk
okay as you know me the result he
doesn't like to wait long to take his
walks okay I'll cover you at that time
yeah I didn't I just stick him for a
nice walk before the stream but I four
hours is too much for him he can't get
enough of walks yes sir Jason walks
that's it that's his life he might be
sleeping so we'll see when he wakes up
Jerry Seinfeld yeah okay what do we have
here I think we have a virus pressuring
so Oprah vision again pressuring
let's see Roxy 7 no 94 OC so the truck
is going somewhere else maybe 7 taking
the two bishops and that is it and he
has enough time to win this but he will
think of something
probably like grandmasters do right yes
yeah I was actually considering Bishop
basics but it's defendant and now real
characters d3 but still defendant oh
yeah
maybe so what is the point if you're
coming for him so we have a bizarre game
between no provisions yes the berserk
because the warning does come oh okay I
didn't capture the Queen I think this is
actually an opening of some kind really
this is a variation yes but white could
have captured the Queen no you didn't
you captured on c7 instead of d8 or it
was maybe it was so fast no no but I
think we'll be able to see it here
because here it is 15 seconds late no
we're already in this oh it's already
that part oh yeah but you can see how
Jordan is actually he is only 7 seconds
8 seconds and he'll opera is in 30
seconds hmm so Jordan is just like
playing
yes link just that's it's always easier
to berserk with white ok let's see what
Queen takes on f1 a suffer if you
learned eleven months ago yeah I'd say
1300 is is very nice Oprah isn't quickly
won the game and now I guess yeah oh
she's back but warning is still in a
very nice streak chess King okay another
player who is not titled in top 10 very
nice okay let's continue with looking
the top games Oh provision against mo mo
mo - hmm okay okay six definitely why
not
an innovation
in this position Andrew cave six very
strong and what yeah will you take the
Queen I will take your queen and take on
be seven so what will you do Oh
provision okay awesome
hmm no this is this is some good
solutions here this is just yeah
threatening okay a video with the Smith
Mora gambit I think I made one like I
don't know be could be a month ago
actually submit more a gambit yeah I
could but you know just do suggest it
ah yes bureau that's correct you don't
play everyone against everyone you know
you have to finish your games fast so we
can play more games you can gain more
points yeah that's like a very big
free-for-all essentially people just
play play and play yeah
win as many points as you can yeah it
may be even more important to win fast
than to win more yeah even if you lose
doesn't matter berserk yeah it depends
on the strategy yeah okay no I think
like a bit better here could be but
let's see let's see what happens
hmm what will Oprah resin do I think he
will win if he was the one in the
tournament
pressuring on g3 I first check and then
look back to give three but what what
next no disruption doesn't have a place
to go it's yeah it doesn't okay oh yeah
but the won't take yeah I thought you'd
put the night Bishop III robbed you want
with check yeah but he will try he will
try his up ten seconds yeah Oprah does
spend most of his time on bullets he is
very experienced
Zachary says that type of players can
cheat too obviously
so okay ah yeah of course but I mean why
should they in in this cases yeah I mean
it's more like but you know you can
always say you want you want a
tournament with over four hundred four
thousand players okay and upper-upper
games the woman and how are we doing we
have like four minutes left and Oprah is
eight points if you look at warning
warning is really our warning just lost
the game yeah probably
and Chile is over holding that third
kids we didn't watch again okay we watch
one game and he won in a second yeah he
won't like any I think he just finished
one so let's let's watch his game for
yeah I don't think no one can
you over yeah so let's just see this
game mm-hmm and maybe one more game for
the end and that's pretty much it yeah I
don't think her Oprah can be catched in
the end I know someone says over isn't
cheating no I also don't think so
so Oprah vision highest rating was 3100
only chest okay that's maybe somebody
know who this guy's is who this guy is I
never actually checked it does it say on
his profile but I've seen him play for
like years only chest now okay so good
oh that was that was a very nice yeah
exchange sacrifice there's a lot of
tricks up his sleeve yeah but again he
gave up the dark square bishop so what
now oh just take on this X here and now
okay Orpheus is 1680 oh okay okay and
he's doing it really well actually
huh yeah Ruth takes on each tree and I
mean it's a checkmate yeah he missed
that but it was a yeah and he got the
zero rating points for that win okay
let's just check out Opera is in game
for the end okay I think in two minutes
they might still cheese mouse cheese
mouse again and an untitled player but
chilly willie she would I mean if he
lasted the entire tournament I don't
think there was any cheating involved so
very impressive tournament co-president
yet managed to develop his bishops here
just playing with the 90s between he
doesn't need them
okay hmm
what what is his plan here to win to win
against cheese mouse copper is an
onigiri just because his Dutch darling
darling but yeah I BM crow Apple I would
I would like to analyze a couple of
games from this tournament but who could
who could the who could watch all of
them there are I mean but maybe you can
so many somehow like look into the games
of the top players players who actually
won the tournament or yeah of course or
something yeah find some interesting
games from them that's that's possible
but depends what no but I think it looks
good now but I think we would find many
blunders the after analysis after all
it's okay no one expects them to play
yeah of course of course for two minutes
that's quite a game okay yeah here's a
piece up Oh awesome a rock up and my
reason why would he block design but
there is not enough time to somebody -
oh there is oh there is if he wins in
the next three seconds but if he doesn't
he still gets reading but not the
tournament points oh and it was so close
yeah only two points Wow
chilli really in the end fourth and
maybe with the same amount of points
with kick it
no let's just check out the top 10 okay
okay I will just give it a couple of
seconds to refresh because they might
[Music]
they might change it as
I remember once I immediately like
copied the list to publish it on
Facebook and then then it's changed okay
due to some cheaters I mean I think
there are cheaters always but you know
we'll just we'll just give it a couple
of seconds so even though operas and
lost his final game he managed to end up
oh but that was oh yeah yeah you don't
know what was the current score of but
you can see the warning plate like 10
games less 8 games less than Oprah
vision so okay since you are the
tournament director I I encourage you to
pronounce the winners of the tournament
oh thank you for this thank you for this
honor so guys after this great
tournament I really enjoyed it
as we have it here haven't matters $500
arena first place goes to Oprah vision
congratulations very good games we saw a
lot of your games it was really nice
second place the warning and third place
kick it okay I'm just pronouncing as I
see it sorry for mispronunciations great
great games guys also chilly willie on
the 4th place we also saw some of your
games pop G sorry if we cursed you in
any way
Tucker Joseph chess Network very nice to
hear ya here Jerry got back into the top
ten reserved a lot of games maybe played
most of the games in the tournament as
you can see here
Gannicus was the stream during the
tournament urine VDS via Tortuga who I
believe joined a little bit after yeah
maybe like even 45 minutes after but he
also preserved a lot of games and
managed to get in top ten but you see
maybe yeah let's see a couple more maybe
even the top 20 and is this some cow eye
eye that's always like that when you
finish the tournament I think you have
to refresh it or something
okay let's refresh and okay
yeah okay now you can oh we had a very
very successful player in 11th place
yeah my other Wes master Peche yeah well
pretty low rating at that point oh yeah
joint very late chess King also saw him
miss your beginner Indian lost a lot of
games I think he started with 2500 yeah
but he had to hear to berserk a lot you
had to catch up yeah but you can see
that even with close to 100 points it
wasn't enough so the tenth player 400
points you have to be six oh okay hmm
four thousand three hundred and ninety
four players in the end yeah that's uh
that's that's about four thousand more
than in my previous tournament okay I
will blow that but but around twelve
teen as you said your Instagram friend
where is where is actually Beatles
Biddle because when 23rd but yeah 23 I
mean two hours of such extreme chess
that's that insane so yeah check back if
the if the tournament stayed the same so
operating still in first GM the warning
second and he gets in third very nice so
I don't know this doesn't this doesn't
say anywhere but for those of you who
want the tournament and who are of
course waiting to receive your prizes
they will be awarded to and in about
three days as it said so says so in the
description here and another thing is
you have to leave me some of your data
so do contact me over leeches or or by
any means but or better yet I will
contact you either way you know as soon
as leeches says that everything is fine
you will be contacted and and paid your
price info yeah do you maybe know how
does leeches actually figure out if you
know I have no idea me neither
so unfortunately we have this case for
the third place and both the players
have 117 but I really don't
no paw yet Chilly Willy chilly willie
also 117 huh yeah yet I mean probably
more games no no I don't think it is I
mean they have some sort of a criteria
yeah okay but we are not really sure oh
yeah yeah I saw a Carlson go berserk it
was a very wasn't saying okay so that's
that's that's it for this tournament I
will now take just men outside for a
couple of minutes and when I return we
will we'll start with the giveaways okay
till then feel free to take up a couple
of challenges so guys let's do it like
this challenge me for three minutes or
less casual games and yeah I'll try and
take up as many challenges until we
until I can yes and I feel the turn I
will bring you more beer as I see your
glass is empty so it's always empty man
see you soon okay okay everybody wants
to place but no I see a lot of
challenges now so I will just dismiss
those long challenges a couple of days
and go in order so please don't hate me
for that but yes I just tried to play
fast and try and win as many as many
games as possible not win but play as
many games as possible so max Murph -
are you here man and yeah I would
encourage you to play right away so that
we can try and play as many playing
games as possible okay before here
keep the bishop take money to something
like this see if I after f4 okay the
name only Ches for this leeches account
is I got matter and if you're wondering
for my leeches account it's Almighty
actually the information is in the
description down below
I would also like to take this chance if
probably Tony adamant will mention it
again
do ya mention also my leeches username
so if you want you can also blame me
okay greetings from Croatia yeah so
97-95
something like that and try to take up
as much as possible in the center I
don't think Crowson was in the
tournament it would be nice if you
joined but yeah he was probably tired
tired from the playing Fisher random
chess with with Nakamura so yeah I guess
he also deserves a little bit of a
little bit of rest to maybe to last for
the next tournament yeah so the
challenges will be played on bleachers
calm how do you challenge on leeches
only chest you have this in the so in
the top navigation bar you have this
little to Swartz crossing each other and
you can just click on them and you can
give a challenge and you write the
username other matter and then the
challenge comes to us and you are in
this list a fairly long list of now 82
players but yeah everybody wants to play
the next tournament yeah I'm not really
sure we will have to ask are the matter
that but judging by the people who want
to play I would guess even really soon
know the giveaways aren't weren't given
right away
so first we played the tournament and
now after I got Metro comes back then
we'll get there will be some prizes to
give away okay let's take here get give
a check age five oh no sorry sorry
no drawers no drawers no worries
maximov good game so next casual game
Eddie and white dope
okay let's play okay Filipino we will go
this time in order yeah good luck to you
add wydo have a good game also here yeah
we'll go in order
who won so the winner of the of the
tournament was Oprah vision he played a
really nice tournament it seemed like he
would win easily but in the end it was
like only two points difference between
first place and the second place Mario
of course yeah I owe you a rematch I
think we will be able to play it in the
string oh I'm all sleep okay okay thanks
meadow did you enjoy the walk so who won
yeah Oh Perez in one right opera resin
one opera version won second place went
to warning and the third place 2/5 get
I'm not sure how to pronounce that okay
yeah I guess I am a lower rated player
since I'm just giving out pieces off of
that not paying attention perfectly fine
but yeah as usual I will publish the
names of all the winners on my Facebook
and Twitter page so make sure your
congratulate everyone the winners and
all how many people order for for fourth
of
4,000 and some for some three hundred or
maybe four thousand four hundred that's
that's like insane and I will I have no
way of contacting the winners now I will
contact them as soon as the stream is
over about the prices but if by any
chance any of them are actually watching
this stream like I said it will take
about three days for Lee just to say
that everything was in order with the
tournament yeah I also like this less
yeah it's uh I think it was this is the
first time actually it's used Oh was
another yeah I think it was like a
birthday present or something you should
give away beer glass wouldn't it be
better to go away beer yeah then beer
glass beer device with beer in it some
kind of a package where it's surprise so
what did you just play I just yeah okay
I lost a piece and now I'm just trying
for something somebody they're playing
two plus one yeah I know yes look at
this chick very nice very nice okay one
plus so a bullet game yeah okay three
minutes three minutes tops but without
increment yeah okay yeah yeah I was just
going yeah we're gonna play I said that
the stream will last for four hours so
that's until 10:30 p.m.
that's like an hour and an hour and 28
minutes more so a lot of games to be
played but we still have two we had we
still have to pick the winners of the
giveaway no two plus two is too much
two plus two can last forever no no
increment Yun just played the two plus
one but we don't accept increments yeah
my mistake there
I have to pay attention yes arranging a
beer tournament that does sound like
like something that chess players will
be interested in okay
I might even marry Wendy she says yeah
and find me next how to enter the
giveaway boy
well that that is that is top secret the
t-shirts are coming along well but the
design for the t-shirts was a bit late
so the t-shirts will be distributed
somewhere around next week maybe two
weeks we'll see but but I do believe
they will be very nice Michael Caine oh
I know this guy yeah I know him yeah yes
also frequent follower on my Twitter
page yes oh yes yes I also yeah I have
them on Facebook and so have fun Michael
King I think I think he records
lightnings oh yes he does like motions
of lightnings origins of storms
I see I think he's a Star Wars fan well
if I'm not wrong who isn't yeah of
course hey not natural Celestia Thank
You Man from Costa Rica again we are
having people from all around the world
so give away please tell me when do you
want to have it the giveaway I don't
know do you want to have it after this
game no I think like maybe after I have
some more beer okay so keep the tension
going on but yeah we'll see maybe after
this game maybe one more game and then
the giveaway so it's better to get get
that out of the way and then after the
giveaways over then we can accept some
challenges until the end of the stream
that is true
Mellie is on the couch only when he
wants to be on the couch it's not like
he's controlled or anything made oh does
what he pleases does this work I guess I
don't see why not
mr. Keane what's wrong with you
Queen thank you thank you mr. Jack Sheen
Black Panther tonight that that's
already it's it's a premier of the Black
Panther like everybody's talking about
do I ever do tournaments outside of
Croatia what do you mean do tournaments
what what was the question I don't know
maybe the question was do I play
tournaments outside the Croatian but no
why I barely play tournaments in Croatia
yeah so said the society could not make
it right me tune I was really really
hoping for you crushing some
grandmasters yeah he do you play or no
why why didn't you play Raj yeah he
played but he played on his mobile phone
oh okay yeah that's a shame
dude of calendar says have you ever lost
Antonio
oh yes I've lost I've lost plenty and
many young Marvel or DC Marvel or DC oh
I have to go for Marvel I think everyone
will go for Marvel yeah so it's like do
you want to be like everybody else or do
you want to try to be different yeah
yeah III just I watched a very nice
interview with sweat was ugly garage
today on YouTube it was like really nice
he did the interview when he was 88
years old so one year before his death
and it was one of the best interviews I
ever saw really so I will have to make
another video about Glee girl is just
just let people know about that
interview although it's not in English
but you know maybe someone waved up some
control sizes well I was actually
considering it but it's it's very long
do you know you go one more and then
we'll do the giveaway and then we'll
switch okay
that sounds reasonable thorny k01 okay
let's try this even though it's not a
good thing to do
how did bottoming do so well to beat
tall in his return match well that's all
that's practically all he did why am i
why am i doing it
Mario even it says young I'm the number
one follower on your channel oh really
oh that's really good to hear I don't
know I I believe I'm the number one
follower oh okay I don't know okay
guys I'm really glad that somebody says
that he's the number one follow because
my channel is really young and yeah yeah
everything for this everyone wants to be
the number one follower thanks for the
support
Mario I didn't know there weren't any
comments or anything I didn't know you
were following Paul Kennedy how often
will I be doing tournaments well this
was a special occasion that's why the
tournament was open to everyone in the
future probably I will again have
passwords and the tournaments will be
closed so it's hard to say I will
probably do some more tournaments with
prizes but they will be there will be
close types with passwords to the
tournaments so I don't know so
subscribers don't don't get scared of
titles players I I think that that was
that was the case in this tournament but
I think other matter subscribers are
warriors yes they are not scared easily
right I think so what I don't know I
thought it was nice as so many type of
players came and you know everyone had
an opportunity to play against a strong
player that is true yeah
okay hmm
now he's gonna push the C pawn no he's
not whoa okay what did I do that why did
I do that it's hard to say yeah it's
really hard to say I'm in the square so
then the name of the friend is yon
almighty and look at him pushing that
bone yay here's what he will try to flag
you with as many people do huh yeah
let's let's do this let's do this okay
you didn't want to grab the phone okay
yeah let's just settle the giveaway and
then therefore they will continue okay
we'll just switch okay let me go closer
to meadow and the price giver gets the
main seat alright so this is how we'll
do the giveaway as usual I will be using
this page it's called comic picker calm
so I have my mighty notepad prepared
here this is the link to the video as
the rules of the giveaway war you have
to leave a comment featuring hashtag
tile to enter the giveaway so first
we'll be picking out ten winners of the
Amazon gift cards and after that we will
take two winners of the championship
chess set so so let's see this I will
let me just get rid of that notepad so I
only prepare the interface for the Lee
chess I didn't prepare it for this but I
will make it work so okay I will just
refresh the page so everything is in
order
paste the link to the video here and
let's just check how many comments are
there
yeah you don't have to write hashtag
towel now yeah yeah that's not how it
works okay there are so many hashtag
towels here you know you had your chance
yes you had to write hashtag doll in the
comments of the video I made on YouTube
so okay let me just bring this over a
little to the left
let me just check if that will be all
right I think that will be fine okay
yeah it's perfect
so let's go picking of the first winner
of the Amazon gift card let's start okay
user names flying let's see if
everything will be in order and we have
June 797 commenting I really love your
contact and keep up the amazing work
hashtag Tao so as there is hashed act
out here everything is in order jook
jook 797 is the first winner so let's
just copy that in our mighty notepad so
first winner will just save that nice
right Amazon okay okay no no first then
our first ten are for the Amazon gift
cards and the second two will be yeah I
I said that it it's it's not cool that
this page does not allow you to pick ten
winners immediately so I will have to
refresh the page after after every
winner but you know something that has
to be done okay so you have whoa okay
2004 bingo days picking of the second
winner let's go let's see those
usernames fly second winner of the
Amazon gift card is Oh
gusto to de saying congratulations man
amazing hashtag tile game by the way
very nice so everything is in order
everybody's writing here still no okay
the second winner is a gusta to de okay
let's say that
going going for the third winner let's
go yeah okay yeah if you right here
sticks out in enough times maybe maybe
something happens to you just commented
on the video maybe maybe maybe it will
work
yeah proud so we have two thousand and
four hundred thirty six from the
previous round it will work so seven
more so people started writing comments
yeah okay but that's that's not against
the rules I did not stay at any time so
okay
thinking of the third winner of the
Amazon giftcard ah we have we have who
do we have
it's mild Diaz you made me love tryst
thank you hashtag doll everything is in
order hash tag Dolly's here as you can
see so third winner mile Diaz let's just
enter depth and a very nice commented
that yes very nice comment let's say
that you know you have to save it in
order to not lose it that's the old
saying okay let's go checking the
comments where do you comment so which
which video was it I was a video where I
say no thank you everyone for for this
epic milestone of reaching 100,000
subscribers you know you know what's up
I'll tell you what's up ya know that's
the video I made before that okay ok
picking winner number four of the Amazon
giftcard it's the doctor three one five
one and it's actually someone from
Zagreb from Croatia okay
yahoo service on stream aleppo service
Agrabah hashtag tell very nice
congratulations
the doctor was enough so every yeah
positive
everything is in order let's just copy
that username here in my mighty notepad
very nice for player for people until or
yeah for my for my next giveaway I will
probably try to find a better website
but for now if you'll have time right
yeah for now
yes very nice Congrats the doctor it's
very nice to congratulate doctors are we
celebrating with some rakia yes
definitely
I'm just a guest I don't know okay
picking the winner number five you see
how you actually jumped with 150 new
commenters really yeah during this very
nice okay Oh mr. hazelnuts oh there's a
lot of things to thanks to her channel I
am back in love with this game after
years of hyah hyah this is like absence
yeah okay there's a question also here
I've seen you mentioned you won your
chest for this tournament and got first
place do you think you're qualified
enough to play okay that's a question
for the for the Q&A so I will answer
that in a video but as you can see here
thanks hashtag doll everything is in
order
so mr. hazelnuts is our winner number 5
very nice congratulations mr. hazelnuts
very good very nice mr. hazelnuts and
all capital letters
oh no it's every second capital letter
even better okay so let's let's repeat
okay this is going a lot faster than I
thought actually very nice because now
you're into it you're already
experienced with yeah how to do it I'm
very happy as I saw there were a lot of
comments this website doesn't let you
filter out only the hashtag tell
comments okay so I thought you know if
we get a comment that doesn't have any
restrictive then we're gonna have to
repeat it but oh yeah sure for now we're
like 5 5 out of 5 and yeah we are ok
25 25 36 number of comments is growing
yeah everybody wants to win that Amazon
gift card in that chess set of course
yes okay we have Diego roses our matter
will be the first 1 million subs channel
hashtag doll ovarian
very nice very nice Thank You mr. Diego
and also there is hash tactile so
everything is in order
congratulations man I would invite all
of you to drink beer for that for that 1
million yes very nice fish I also
believe there will be a lot of beer for
reaching 1 million
okay so we're six out of six these are
the winners let's let's get ready for
winner number seven okay let's see the
the comments okay
twenty-five for one it's still rising
still rising let's see good luck to
everyone will it be a tell comment it
must be okay another no comments lend
Erik great work hashtag towel very nice
nice and sweet congratulations slend
Erik okay pasting you into the notepad
it's really a mighty note that yeah it
is I mean without it I never do anything
without notepad okay let's just paste it
here let's go
so we have we're seven out of seven
mm-hmm three more and then on to the
championship chess set even though I'm
not in the game I'm really excited you
didn't accept played no no I I thought
it wouldn't be fair
no I know I don't know you always give
me beer so I guess that's enough for me
yeah I don't need the Amazon giftcards
chess it okay okay is that that's you
know directly to the point
you know just like doll would do it just
like in the comments right now in the
chat yeah state though so we don't have
a hashtag doll so everything is in order
congratulations son to be a lot it would
be nice if you wrote something but okay
no that's not the rule you have to write
a check top it says any comment plus a
stack top
so like zero characters plus yeah even
just spaced hair shape doll is also nice
so I believe we're eight out of eight
yes one two three four five six seven
eight eight out of eight
very nice two more Thank You jewels from
Pittsburgh thank you very much okay
counting the comments and let's see 25
five seven okay
picking winner number nine let's go Oh
user names are flying we have the
perfect ten I believe so
okay greetings from Slovakia very nice
Patrick chair me hashtag dollar nice
everything seems to be in order
so congratulations mr. Patrick journey
let's just enter that here and for the
for the final winner of the Amazon
giftcard I just refresh that let's go
enter okay
enter doesn't work well I will have to
email whoever created this website
random picker guy yeah okay so this is
the last winner of the Amazon gift card
and then we go pick two winners of the
championship chess set
oh that will be exciting yes it's it's
well that we sit so from the beginning
of the giveaway everybody is writing
here sticks up in the chit yeah but it's
you know they're supporting yes that's
how much support there is in the chat
okay okay
picking winner number 10 let's go the
less Amazon gift card goes to mmm-hmm
and it's hashtag tile the chicken
fighter
congratulations mister chicken fighter
everything is in order
hashtag tile is here very nice okay this
chicken fighter is trolling me
okay let's copy that awesome enter so we
have our 10 winners I believe whoa not
bad what are you doing man too many
saves yeah probably
no there's something
the last character is rooms ah okay
something I will use something else then
it doesn't matter so okay we have the
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten that's excellent
and now sorry I think there is a
character that ya know that doesn't
recognize it probably the the guy from
Slovakia okay so here it is picking the
winner of the championship chess set
no vehicle slot decided to ditch us he
had he had important things to do maybe
he has a girl or something who knows
yeah you never know yeah okay so the
first winner of the first championship
chess set is I really have to get on
roll sorry guys
okay and the winner of the championship
chess set is okay I've been enjoying
your content for quite some time and
you're the reason why I was actually
able to improve my game can thank you
enough cash deck towel everything is in
order
congratulations mister I fab so very
nice let's just grab that into notepad
very nice and we also have a second
winner of the championship chess set as
this time we have two championship chess
sets so this is the last prize of the
giveaway but I will give out some
t-shirts in about a week so don't don't
be sad if you don't win this one so
let's check out load all the comments
yeah I felt yeah that's what I read
though yeah less price let's see who
does the website favor
it's a really nice name for the website
if you think about it comments picker
yeah it makes sense
straight to the point yeah okay so and
the winner of the second championship
chess set and this is in fact the last
prize of the giveaway goes to and it's
max wake congratulations on reaching
100k hashtag doll very nice
congratulations mr. max wake yeah I
think we ended up with a really good
comment for the end definitely so those
those were the winners congratulations
to everyone who won and congratulations
guys
I mean there are so many people and so
little prizes but you know I I thought
it it makes sense the award at least
someone I mean if you didn't win that's
there's always two hundred thousand and
1 million so don't worry of what of
subscribers and then giveaways
milestones are coming definitely yeah
but yeah I will need your help on
deciding I have some I already have some
designs for t-shirts but I will also
include you unchosen what what is the
best design so I will publish the
winners on my on all of my social
networks on Facebook Twitter Instagram
probably everything they have so and in
my video of course so do you are
required to contact me using this
username that was picked through youtube
that was the custom in previous
giveaways everything was always in order
so I don't think there there will be a
problem so yeah that's the giveaway I do
hope you enjoyed it you know now we
return then really chess OHS I actually
forgot to to remove the to remove the
interface for leeches during the
giveaway but you know oh you mean the
yeah
having a party for his celebrating the
birth of his son okay
whoo-hoo-hoo he named eleven after
eleven Oregon
so me and yon will be joining them after
the stream so you know it's a pretty big
celebration you know he did get get a
son Mario never do that no one is
normally spamming hashtag towel because
well there was no reason to spam hashtag
tau in the first place I will definitely
play against Mario one of the games he
said that he chose chess before his
girlfriend I have a it's Bruno Parvati
which challenge of the bullet is against
the new guy at chess central's yeah yeah
he's the new guy at chess Central's okay
okay let's test him out but I don't know
if you're here
yeah enjoy the game I will go for beers
yo-yo okay try to find them I don't know
where they are
okay I don't think we did
guess let's go d5 immediately see how
see how Bruno will will play this okay
let's capture capture and not allow
that's to be captured that seems
reasonable let's spin that night also
seems like like a nice idea let's go
here and probably push the night now go
here I don't want to do that maybe like
this let's exchange everything ah that
wasn't really the best plan Oh Bruno
Bruno is so powerful but what what what
happens now after I pinned the night
octopus captures and now we enter the
end game but he makes it to the pawn
damn it thought you wouldn't make it to
the pawn
Oh even that even that oh I can so
resign this thought he wouldn't make it
to the bone
and he's so fast
Bruno is a monster
is it yes he is now he's gonna grab my C
pawn no it's not now he's gonna grab it
okay good game Bruno yes it Bruno is
very strong very strong indeed
next time Bruno as we do have a lot of
people to play so what do you think like
three games and then do we switch or
yeah seems reasonable mmm-hmm okay
bullet so that we play yeah okay
whatever
yeah okay first first we're gonna go
with a couple of bullet bullets
challenges - sure - sure calm day okay
that was a very intense game Bruno is
very strong okay let's go here try and
grab that yeah Bruno from new guy from
chess central's yeah okay very strong
what's good here
so you can join no worries Bruno yeah
thanks you for joining this world yeah
it's kind of a rule on the stream so not
to accept free matches although you
definitely you definitely earned one
that was one one one great game so to
join you actually have only just these
two swords on top of the top of the
browser you click on them and you write
the username eigen matter and then you
just challenge yeah that's that's how
you do it do it as a casual game and
yeah we prefer a lower time limit so
that we can play as many people as
possible yeah more
more games equals more fun okay I I just
probably shouldn't have done that but
what are we doing
hello are you blundering again yes I'm
blundering it terribly okay
I'm blundering terribly what is this
really doing there I have no idea he
went for a walk yeah I have to play it
like this what now rook rook here
probably I'm done for 9 seconds I forgot
it's hard to play bullet when when you
don't hear the moves don't think about
it
just play it it's my move okay yeah
sorry oh he missed it it's checking okay
very nice very nice
any more any more bullet interesting
games okay zero zero 90 Thank You Aaron
the air in the Aaron is this the most
viewed live stream oh yes it is by far
definitely over thousand people I think
there was 1800 actually yeah yeah 1800
what I buddy was a go before just after
a couple of minutes it was it was over a
thousand play people okay okay I will do
this okay there's no reason not to do it
okay let's see what he plays first so go
like this okay
Queen b3 no that's what you did to me
man suggest all the best moves right
just push some phones I guess let's go
here captures captures
have to play faster as I don't hear the
moves capture scalpers probably so there
are now 114 challenges really we'll try
and play as many as possible but yeah
yeah definitely this is my move no no it
isn't I'll probably want to put d5
whatever he plays oh he's gonna go that
very nice I kind of hoped he would
okay capture capture who she's gonna
capture the night but it's fine okay
yeah I don't think she wants to go away
with the Queen at this position no Queen
g7 better yeah cover with the Queen I
don't I don't care because no you said
it no I can't put okay sorry I will just
focus on the chat yeah let's go here
what trick so thanks to all of you again
thanks to all of you who joined and now
how to go to sleep since I saw somebody
wrote it was 5:00 a.m. yeah that's
really nice hope you can joy also next
time yeah definitely I mean it's a
different time everywhere it's really
hard to pick up the best time for the
stream you know yeah but I don't know as
most of my viewers are from the United
States I thought this you know this
would cover it nicely yeah okay what do
we have here I'll get them long time
okay oh I'll take that straight and that
one yeah we also like it because it's
right after our work my work yeah what
about your work I will right after my
working hours so I work like all the
time yeah
okay let's straight that okay we were
like just trading everything and he
wants to trade even more but okay I
don't mind
215 in India so 215 like Oh in the
morning it's a porn ending this is this
is terrible
do you watch my videos now we will see
what's the main role in the pond and you
have more points give the opposition
this seems like the reasonable idea yeah
besides have more phones keep the
opposition and I expend yes but he who
has more pawns will keep the opposition
okay see ya that's what happens Oh
oh man and now what okay but this is
drone yeah because I cannot nobody can
run everywhere I have the opposition oh
you don't have diagonal so maybe I will
have it no no what what are you doing
I'm getting gaining opposition this is
not see that's how you gain a position
and now I yeah okay
nice nice display of like getting a
position for mother mother here oh yeah
Rob I'm really proud because I was I was
up a pawn so it wasn't really that hard
but you know now your five points more
so yes now now I push the pawns and
anything can happen
you really know your opponent knows he
might have left what good game ok we
have string dog string what string dog
okay man yeah masterful demonstration of
opposition but I I I prefer to have more
points that's oh and we have always good
to have ya string dog is also a
supporter of leeches very nice
okay so this is very symmetrical so
let's see how long I can keep I can keep
doing this okay let's go here
huh go for that at Foursquare seniors
reasonable okay and let's just grab it
[Music]
yeah that's that's that's a pretty nice
idea yes the defendant but now I can
simply I can simply grab it
and then grab the rook I guess now it's
not much but I'll take the exchange
exchanger oh yeah I mean I have no she's
you'll capture your king
no he won't he wants to push himself
here hello okay awesome all right Bruno
poetry says I should teach vehicles on
my endgame techniques I don't know yeah
maybe he says he's a tactics guy who via
KHOU yeah really yeah I thought he was
like only in game player I don't know
that's what I that's what he says he
says I wouldn't say I really like Mia at
this game so that's amazing yeah but I
guess since you joined chess essentials
you know about him more than we do so
yeah please do helping me watches
I think Jeff isn't here actually so
we'll have to abort this and I don't
think there are any more bullet
challenges so okay now we can
play something yeah okay gyro the dog
got a couple of bucks for the for the
celebration though he and he had like
five meals today and yeah okay so this
is two minute okay what do we have 95
maybe no yes 95 is here caption notice
I'm not yet drunk I will be drunk
afterwards so don't worry huh oh we have
we have debt very nice and now what
that's just like a really old line which
is very cool really yes it's like a bit
different from 95 but if he doesn't know
it then it is gonna be pretty weird for
him but do you know yes I know it okay
ah so that's how you wanna play it all
right sir
yes and now you see I control the III
square like a boss oh he does it
immediately very nice well done but what
about after I played this I just move my
leg three yes but it's not all that's
clear because now I have this and the
roof - do you want nc5 okay mission p3
it doesn't matter nothing matters in
love and war although that could matter
yes I was I was very hasty I didn't want
to move my king he doesn't even like
that I'm just gonna Park it here hmm
okay seems reasonable the strong bishop
Croatians actually do have middle names
oh yeah of course I like from the
questioning you get the middle name yeah
I don't want to play five here you're
gonna take the pawn on e5 No
because because I don't want to allow f3
now I'm gonna do it like this
now I guard everything such a gardener
yes do I want to give him this pawn I
don't know yeah oh just looking will you
sit like a good pawn it would be a shame
to give such give up such a pawn he
already played it hmm that's interesting
let's just kick this night and see what
he does
bunny first we're gonna go c5 we're not
gonna go c5 I have to I can't
hmm no you're good here yeah but it's
not very it's not very well don't you
what did you play aces Ruby it because
a6 then I get this check I have to move
and then yes but I don't mind it now
okay okay
yes what up now I push but what about 92
I could've won that but this is even
stronger okay I just see now I played
this no this loves chick hmm yeah that's
this is probably something I missed as
well but you can Freddie you can play
all over the website you don't have to
download the mobile app yeah I mean the
name of the app is leeches just like the
name Oh No oh very nice trick but you
can capture yeah yeah but he can't
capture my strongpoint that's the
problem
hmm but he doesn't want to but where's
the night going here and then attacked
from behind that's your style
that's some hyperbolic magic of course
what no this is not happening okay
why so what's he's too fast
come on oh man means he's so fast
very nice job I was very impressive okay
you deserve to you deserve to play oh
thank you i deserted by you losing oh
great game mr. gyro 90 let's try and
find some some bullet games Oh
130 yeah but should I go here or should
I play from the top you're the
tournament director but I don't know if
it is brought from the top I still
haven't figured that out okay there is a
one challenge for you actually
oh I see it have a mint so let's focus
on this
neither three doesn't matter what Excel
or Excel or please final let's go for
some
captain Nautilus says that on a scale
from one to ten he's drunk six
who me no no mr. captain Nautilus he
asks uh how far up the scale am I now
not that much maybe maybe a three could
be a four but we all drop yeah no come
on in look at our chess skill yeah I
mean this is like top level [ __ ] makes
you one no not yet but now yes 94 93 hmm
95 let's see what he does now just going
for that I'll just capture this yeah you
just gave up this how would you play if
towel played against you with severe
caution Oh Queen g5 capture capture and
this ship very nice
awesome yeah I would definitely play
like it play usually very graceful oh
you remember master Mac he was number 11
in the tournament
oh okay we've but I don't think he
berserk berserk I don't know come on Oh
No jump but he I think he didn't lose a
single game
Obert will this night go very
interesting okay yeah yeah yes it's
called the kuda no I don't think they
can pull it off even if they had like
forever but then again who knows know if
six not have six come on yeah everyone
wants to play against Magnus oh she's
not even worried about that even better
what now
how's he gonna get the Brooks into the
game no yeah it's yeah he's pretty good
yeah okay well very nice oh I'm just
really bad no but he won the 11th place
in the tournament out of four over 4,000
people
I have very nice without losing a single
game this is really bad for me but okay
it happens it happens in Bullitt what
can you do
it happens in classical as well
yeah that's uh I actually know that one
Eduardo which one cow chick who got the
giveaway well we picked all the rules of
the giveaway a couple of people yeah
twelve people one I will show them for
the end of the stream once more but I
will publish all the winners I'm on all
of my social media and will mention them
in the next video and also put them in
the description of this video so who
wanted that person will definitely know
that he want it less mess yes that's
quite a name a good night good night mr.
ash won't sing okay you have to take me
to Mars challenge next meeting garage
has to sleep okay and I have to take
Murray even de challenge as well or
there are many challenges as many people
of course happy birthday to mr. Nicki
arts don't know if that's how you
pronounce it gadgets world what do you
mean skipping but I never skip a thing
okay where's me to Raj can we search
with control life no I don't yes even
ditch Mario trip I think I think we can
actually let's try and try Raj enter
yeah oh there it is there it is okay hey
Raj like oh I can with the black
everybody's challenges so they're
they're white oh really
it isn't fair I thought it's like random
but you can set it up when you challenge
know what they wouldn't do that no you
can yeah I mean I know we can but I
don't think they would do that
you don't know your subscribers yeah I
don't think we have nowhere to place a
real chess board now that would have to
be a completely different set up okay
how is there a from attune doing very
well so it's yeah pretty equal so right
when we tune is up a pawn there nice hop
up ii can he pull off i'm up the second
it's gonna be very very interesting no
back he's trying to checkmate you what
was happen now okay that was a nice
decision okay really it really pushed
that bad boy
yeah can I take it actually I'm not sure
yep he wants to Ronnie move you you want
it Rory move you can I just play against
Mario and then it's your turn okay okay
yeah Mario was up here but it's three
plus so is that okay mmm I don't know
yes okay he's been waiting the whole
stream yeah I think a lot of people
actually were but let's just quickly
play Mario it's just you know that's one
thing I think Lily chest should make for
screaming like that there is an actual
list and then then you joined the game
automatically that would make sense and
he even said that he chose chess over
his girlfriend so if I don't play my
feel really bad is he telling the truth
that I'm not sure I don't know that's
why he's your subscriber but he also
said his mind so I will get to know you
that he's your first follower okay I
hope you're not lying Mario okay Oh Nick
Gertz is your cat I really thought that
was a person
what I'm missing all the job this way
Eduardo oh yeah you you are well noticed
Arvind
ah look after the giveaway is over yeah
you missed it unfortunately yeah bodrov
Yost planning says it's Livonia because
poor effects what about his poor effects
I already did that video top 10 facts I
mean about the sparrow yeah that was uh
who that was that was so long ago that
was like in 2015 16 I don't know those
were the days
thanks man always always wanted to have
a beer debt Diggs I think Mario urine
problems Mario is always in problems he
will now play the greatest move okay I
think that is it
well played I like it okay it's your
turn okay Mario now go back to a
girlfriend and say sorry also from from
me yes and we will say that you want
yeah in great style if anybody is proud
yeah it was worth it yeah okay okay I
have a hyper bullet waiting here so
that's something you always accept yes
but it will be somewhat difficult since
can't really hear any of the moves but
that's fine
better better just to push
okay good game mr. Kesh avila cache of
chess good game oh I just look at look
at my phone and all riders again you
were looking at it for quite some time
okay there are no more 1 plus so long as
mr. less miss yes also the UI from the
chat I can't hear the moves because when
when I'm streaming I have to wear
headphones to hear the sound because I
mute it so it doesn't interfere okay
that's a nice born playing very fast I
will grab it do a multi Yelich
impersonation do you know how to do it I
don't know how to do it I would have to
I would have to I could probably do it
although I don't I I don't want to do it
okay yeah I'll grab it yeah guys there
there are a lot of challenges so if you
did it also a half an hour ago
yeah and fortunately it is what it is
hey Lobo critic hope I'm not not getting
checkmated
okay let's let's improve here the rock
lift
yes the mighty roof lift tips for a
starting player what are the tips Madden
I I always say first study the end game
roll Dino is asking to play against
Philip but yeah this is just about
everybody wanted to play so okay there
goes the Queen the Queen went grocery
shopping and yeah yeah okay this is this
Bishop is just terribly in the way
yeah took it rid of all my light square
bishop and then I can trick me come on
take it but this is also good game man
good game okay let's let's see where you
see this is okay let's go it's a family
tie yeah do it okay let's let's go so
the best book for chess openings is
depends on the opening you like he
tricked me he didn't want to go for my
pawn very nice
okay Eduardo is like ah he's going for
that the joke again with the dog a park
I'm gonna try and trick fill it with a
meaningless Bishop sacrifice I really I
remember when Philip was here last time
and I said that he's playing really good
he is a monster and he said I'm not a
monster
no this guy okay that was something else
let's go let's go f4
or is the best f4 is the best
everything is open I don't mind a lot of
threats no I'm just thinking about black
not you I know I like what position you
know what let's just bring the other
rook into the game as well play
aggressive movement
oh you see oh no I don't everything
falls apart
no it's actually fine the bishop has to
move probably can't save everything play
okay I can't do it I I want a route C 1
I don't know what Roxy 1 is next here
you would have captured in the rook c8
checkmate I think I think this will be
but you never know as he is a monster
yeah after all he broke he accepted that
he is a monster here and now we already
see improvement in his game that's
correct
but now how can he how can he stop this
terrifying attack oh she's trying to
trick me
yeah we'll trick treat me with a trick
let's go here and now push now I have to
take care of some tricks and that will
be it
now if he captures I simply grab the
night if he doesn't good game you grab
the check me grab a checkmate doughnuts
doughnuts
all right mr. to nibs and this chat has
been really fast yeah I don't this okay
mr. tarnish is here let's go for the
let's see what he plays okay yeah I also
think so you should sacrifice your queen
right away and then try and win the game
all right right away like I see Queen to
be 16 to be to us okay I do that in
bullets and but not on purpose
hyperbolic yes but not on purpose what
just happened
what is this this is some sorcery drink
beer for each pawn and a shot for each
piece that's actually a great idea but
it's at the end of the string almost
yeah 15 minutes so wouldn't make sense
really but yeah actually a nice idea for
some of the future strings
yes definitely those are actually some
nice moves
yeah I also like the Kasparov blunder
face made by Ivan Madar in that video in
one of the videos when you went like
this with your hands over the face haha
oh yeah yeah a replica of a Kasparov
blunder face yeah I mean I had to do it
there was there was no way around it no
I also thought so
okay does this porn counter something
there I mean there triples I guess not
no actually I'm not his brother I'm his
neighbor yeah which is even better we
can hang out occasionally and drink a
beer we don't have to fight it or
anything yeah no not right as as we're
both using this account so we don't have
to log in all the time it's my move no
let's now what
what's the trick I don't think there is
one hmm it's interesting tournament was
won by Oh provision but I will I will
contact everyone who needs to be
contacted don't contact it don't worry
yeah just Sharma so what is ha ha well
really played oh yeah for those of you
who are maybe just joining in at the
giveaway is over but I will publish the
names of the winners of the giveaway
like I said on all my social media so my
use my username is actually almighty
actually the all the information you
need is in the description down below so
yeah yeah actually whenever you find me
online I'm always glad to play a game so
here I see agamotto is pretty much
pretty much up a queen and a piece is
what you know it's 30 seconds anything
can happen
donuts did you play some games in
Germany in Germany yeah when you were in
your vacation no didn't have the time
no one was playing actually Germans
aren't Chester's no we went to to one
chess club but then no one was
interested and in the second chess club
no it's not as no one was interested but
they were having their official
tournament so we couldn't play with them
and that's about it they only have like
gatherings on Fridays and there was just
no way to do it
okay okay is there mate
there is no mate there is a win on time
oh yeah
okay mr. Nimmo sharks okay let's see if
we have some shorter time controls yeah
Schrodinger mr. Schroedinger is probably
equation but I don't think is here
okay let's just push that hello Emmanuel
get well because I said guy has a fever
yeah drink a lot of tea and play a lot
of chess yeah that will help you get
well Ethan Bradberry oh my god
Ethan Bradberry really what are you an
h3 h3 fan uh well I don't really watch
it like all the time but if I get the
opportunity I will watch it is so the
Ethan Bradberry just wrote a comment on
the chat I'm not sure if it's the right
Ethan Bradberry I mean the real one but
yeah I don't think it's the real one is
there's no profile photo what it's just
as well oh I'm done 27 seconds you are
talking and then I'm missing on time
okay sorry
never stop talking you're you're always
tricking me yeah what about the basics
now probably you won't see Bishop e6
very classy
Felix what's with no worries Emanuel
take the layin that King is now stuck
there okay Schrodinger go here seems
reasonable okay sir
let's just create some sort of a meeting
knit again okay mister floating earth it
seems how many games you play the
challenge just keep there more and more
challenge yes okay I guess mmm-hmm
pretty much at the end oh yeah you can
play two more games after this and I
believe that will be it
yeah I know mr. beast I know I have a
I'm still new at making videos and I I
really gotta get a bit better on it for
eight for a DAT I saw that YouTube is
making my videos 480p but yeah I'll try
and make him 720p and 1080p don't worry
sorry for that yeah does does anyone
does anyone maybe have news about my
latest video is it still in 360p because
that was very very annoying okay I guess
there should be five d5 okay one is the
goat thanks Sam yeah I will improve the
quality of the videos as soon as I
figure out how to make it how to make it
more than 480p maybe some hey I'm not
really very well versed of those video
editing stuff I'm pretty I'm still
pretty new at that stuff but okay I
guess I will figure it out so anybody
who is so anybody wants to challenge me
it's free to challenge me okay not now
but at some other time my user is
almighty and yeah we can play so yeah
your video is still three 360 360 I'm
gonna have to contact someone about that
that's like very rude I uploaded it like
3 p.m. something below 3 p.m. it's not
cool
not cool okay I will do probably opening
videos and some instructional videos on
how to do openings and transfer in the
middle game but yeah the thing is I
don't have that much time
and I'm now doing mostly I'm game videos
so that will probably come sometime next
in the future Jane Hamas's one ATP so it
is one ATP or it isn't one ATP okay good
game okay you want to play one more yeah
we have like until yeah to good bullet
games nether is right here she just
drank some water yes and he always wants
to go for a walk so let's try and find
some bullet games okay there is a dray
casual okay always expanding Center even
if it's the first two moves hmm c3 c4
which would be to take all take all the
pawns
no no the Bryce Watson the Q&A will be
in the separate video that will be
called the Q&A the patron versus missile
is still 360 I'm just gonna delete that
video that's no why
it's 360 doesn't matter no just drop the
night there
I noticed that something was very weird
when I uploaded it as the processing
went extremely slowly so it could
perhaps to be processing maybe it's like
a busy day for YouTube or something so
who knows
sir strange look at this beautiful
necktie for was possible but okay 97 No
okay that works now to f6 okay okay that
was well good game mr. Audrey let's play
against mr. Nick to 497 I guess this is
a rating to you that you want right guy
what that that would be definitely my
order rating are you here mr. Nick to
four yes you are maybe time traveler
25th century maybe and he is here to
teach us some chess eight-six thanks
move okay maybe seven taken c4 okay you
take hmm very nice okay now I spent here
oh wow yeah that's the problem you don't
see when it's your turn
yeah seconds all the time what CD we
guys from we guys from Chrissy young do
the blender face wait wait I'll do it
I'll do it I'll do it
come on sit when I blunder something I
hope you'll do it I'll do it for him
and with that face I believe that's it
do you want to do want to say something
for the for the end of the stream of
course I do
once again congratulations to the
hundreds K also from me and thank you
all of you guys for for joining it has
been awesome really awesome see all of
those games from the tournament with all
the top players and also from you guys
playing and this giveaway and all the
happiness and all the good comments yeah
just been really great so thank you for
asking me to join and yeah I'm hoping
that I'll be asked again for the next
milestone of course okay you can bet I
okay so yeah guys that's it like I said
all the winners of the giveaway will be
posted on all my social media and the
winners of the tournament as well I will
contact you through leechers but I will
also publish your names
all of my social media and that will be
probably in the next hour so you should
know all the information needed so
that's it I do hope you enjoyed the
stream this has been like a record
breaker and like everything for my
channel I believe over 1,800 people live
stream and over I believe 4400 people
playing actually in the tournament
that's like that's like a really big
happening so yeah I will post more
information I have to contact now
YouTube support to really you know
insult them about my video being 360p
but you know that that's something for
another matter and I will try to make
the Q&A video as soon as possible
so that's that was the stream I do hope
you enjoyed it and everything it that
went with it thank you all for watching
and we will see you soon thank you all